[Music]
good to see you Tony good to see you red
so sweaty
yeah hence if you're watching on YouTube
the wet hair we just got back from a
trail run and a little bit of a running
tutorial we're gonna make a little video
it's gonna be up on YouTube what are you
putting me through my paces and and
showing me what I'm doing wrong and how
I can improve with my technique so I
really appreciate that and we were
joking before the podcast and I've said
this before but I always like to go into
these conversations in a pristine way
like the ideal would be you know you sit
down we haven't even said hello to each
other and we just go and then it's very
organic and authentic but we spent
already like half a day together talking
getting to know each other a little bit
which has been beautiful I know it's to
make a connection first yeah yeah for
sure but I'm probably gonna have to make
you repeat a few things that we already
talked about today thank you for coming
to Los Angeles it makes it more
difficult remembering yeah look man I'm
here I'm present for the experience
that's all I care about and I've been
looking forward to this for a very long
time you've cut a very unique path in
the fitness world and I think that the
knowledge and the wisdom and the
information that you're putting out
there is not only important but unique
what do you think you need maybe now you
know but a lot of it's been gathered
from you know peoples or people that are
living a natural existence and going
into looking at the natural environments
around the world and looking at the
natural beings and seeing how they're
doing it I mean that's really the core
of everything that you teach it's all
rooted in natural practices that we can
trace back to you know civil acient
civilizations you know over the ages and
how humanity kind of acclimated to the
environment and made it work for them
yeah in a in a holistic way as opposed
to a kind of cloistered way that we live
today
as essentially zoo animals who have
become prisoners have the the very
comfortable environments that we've
created for ourselves yeah I worked with
a company called wild fitness nice to
hold retreats and their big presentation
was zoo humans and wild humans aha and
so they take people along this path of
what it is to be a wild human but at the
same time they then say well we're zoo
humans but for me it was just it was
just too much G jarring for people and
always it's an insult in a way you know
so really it's about again making small
little changes I don't want to return to
the wild I wouldn't survive five minutes
none of us would really but it's
certainly looking at areas around a
natural lifestyle and seeing what I can
in be cooperate into my everyday
lifestyle so what came out of that was
we can't all live in nature but it
doesn't mean we can't live naturally so
there's a as we discover there's a
natural way of running which is just
finding the natural posture when running
because natural runners and natural
beings aren't compromised by you know
see seated further furniture a sedentary
lifestyle or compromising footwear so
they can then perform the appropriate
task of running without the risk of
injury like we have a risk of injury
yeah so they haven't changed the form so
and if that's running then running is
just a micro element of movement so then
for me then it was to discover others
and natural where moving it's not just
running running is just a micro element
what about will the other movement
disciplines and so if you had to move
now you discovered moving out here now
what is that a move that's a friend of
mine not um you have the store Irwin
who's named herb when oh when the call
and he set up a system called move NAT
which then looking at running being a
natural movement but then there's others
there's like balancing this jumping as
lifting as carrying this throwing the
swimming as we were just going swimming
earlier I'm defending and so that's the
movement system that we have that he's
then coaching in and then we and then
beneath that well that's again that's we
could be teaching zoo humans into moving
that way but without dealing with the
compromised posture to begin with you
know dealing with a sedentary lifestyle
and compromised
Footwear and shapes surely we're still
hiding the risk of injury mm-hmm so then
for me it was like what what are these
natural beings doing that are different
the ones that are running naturally the
ones that are moving niche naturally
well again you just remove the chair so
I was saying oh yeah I just removed all
the furniture from my home yeah the
chairs out of your house you don't have
one chair in your house no we don't we
just have we ground this so we ground
live and that's been amazing because you
suddenly discover there's like a hundred
different rest positions that you can
choose on the ground uh-huh and we have
one we're sitting down now right yeah
but there's like a hundred different
rest positions so what are the main
complaints I get to see when I'm when
I'm coaching somebody a movement or any
other discipline and it's AMA I've got
lower back pain I've got knee pain
I've got neck pain and you realize that
they're all the areas that really should
be more stable they have a mobility role
but they have a stability role and then
you have areas that are designed
specifically to be more mobile than they
are stable so the ankle joint mobility
the hip joint mobility and the three
core spine more mobility and so they're
the areas that should be mobile but
unfortunate memories let me sit down and
these encounters and the posture that
you get within the couches you slouch
right so we in turn into a slouching
couching typing swiping organism and the
problem is there that then it wipes out
those areas that are designed for
mobility and they get stiff and then the
areas that should be stable and now
getting more more mobility into them mmm
when we talk about lower backs
essentially when the hip and the
mid-back I've kind of lost perception or
you've lost perception of their role and
therefore the lower back gets attacked
so the way we address is just take it to
the ground man and then suddenly it's
like wow look at look at all these
different positions I can be choosing
and that wipes out even things like
standing desks as standard loads of hype
around a standing desk at the moment but
it's just as detrimental to to stand all
day with crappy posture as it is to sit
with crappy posture you know mm-hmm yeah
if you're standing but you're not
adopting proper form then you're doing
harm you know when we talk about form
the danger is where is a webform people
start thinking are I've to tense my core
and squeeze my glutes and all this stuff
but it's that's not it it's basically
going back to what is a wild posture
hunter-gatherers do not tense their core
and squeeze
glutes while they're moving around nor
does any other animal on the planet what
dogs might do they just can't
communicate
thanks to my call right now and
squeezing my glutes you know I mean it
just fit it's not happening but it's
that again what hasn't changed for them
is their environment the environment is
still the same they're still moving the
same through a landscape and they
hunter-gatherers specifically move
through a landscape don't you move for
it they become the landscape I mean they
don't see themselves as separate from it
it's not the standing or the sitting
it's the fact that those are those are
things that we do for extended periods
of time right like even the most fit and
I plead guilty this like I I'm fit I go
I work out every day I train but then
I'm sitting at a desk
even if I'm sitting in an ergonomic
chair I'm still sitting for hours and
hours and hours and sometimes I don't
get up and move around that much
and so yeah I have lower back issues I
have some sciatic issues you know if
you're scrolling and looking at your
phone your neck is tensed up like I know
what that feels like like this is these
are you know things that I think every
single human being is experiencing on
some level no matter how fit you are
we're all sitting too much what is every
sick in because it's almost like we've
we've with fitting two groups here but
every single human being would mean also
hunter-gatherers you see I'm just saying
I'm talking about modern Western yeah
exactly so we're in that so that's like
I have this thing there's 83% of the UK
and living in urban environments and
there's a stat looks like they spend 90
95 percent of their time indoors so
that's like wow okay you guys are
blessed to because you're moving she's
been on an amazing trail and you have
that outdoor experience being in London
it's like sometimes people just
sheltering you know they've got to get
away from what they see is the elements
let's say but let's say they're 90%
their time indoors so 9/10 their time
indoors how do we how do we flip it how
do we make the indoors more nourishing
again and so that for me it has to be if
95 79 spent my time is indoors how much
of that is am i spending sedentary how
do I change that and so that that's been
the biggest cue for me I went into
Santander and did a talk in there the
asset management team
and it was the same thing as soon as I
arrived I met the head of the team and I
said it's your responsibility the first
thing is the air quality in here it's
terrible clean up the air it's probably
worse indoors and is outdoors so put air
purification systems in here and then to
the people that have this their desk
area I said this is your responsibility
you either create a growth-promoting
desk area or a compromising desk area
it's a choice right but here's how you
can make the changes to start with
because a lot of it people don't
understand that there is another way
there is another choice that they can be
making so then it was the okay your HR
department here they wouldn't even let
people hug in you know to hug in the
office not imagine all the happy
hormones you're getting oxytocin you
have for longer you get serotonin well
hugging's tricky these days yeah it's
really tricky I guess it's how long you
hold it for and how uncomfortable it
becomes but this is it's a tough one and
and so that was to me that was like
right the one thing I could it stripped
that but we can't do that that's that's
okay are we allowed standing desks and
there was one person in that whole
office that had a standing desk a let's
just go through what you can be doing if
you have to sit right we set a timer
20 minutes thing timer goes off you just
push your chair back and you hold your
desk and we just squat and you do like
three squats at the desk to reset the
posture and then I want you to walk from
one end of the building to the other and
then come back to your desk done and
every 20 minutes every 20 minutes and
then said to the guy who leads the floor
medi are you okay with that he's like
yeah man this is cool and then right can
the next say I'm going to all have a
plant so peace lilies really easy to
keep so easy you can go away for two
weeks they might be a bit droopy when
you come back be just a little bit water
and then they're up again and that will
remove benzene xylene formaldehyde from
this environment again so put that right
on your desk so then two women just
rushed out immediately run out bought
two piece of lilies put them on their
desk just sit just simple little
adjustments and again it gives them
something living in that environment
that they can then nurture and they have
to look after
what about lighting Lighting's a you
know it's a big one for me um we as well
as not having you furniture in our house
we switched to remote-control bulbs and
amber lighting I should point out you
have three daughters yeah yeah what are
their ages knowing just about 10 10 just
about 10 8 3 year old and a new one on
the way so so they're they're young
enough that getting rid of the chairs is
game and probably fun but we were joking
earlier like fast-forward to them you
know being 2530 years old telling their
therapist that their dad making that
made them take all the chairs out of the
house wait it's funny because we when we
move out the trauma when we move to a
beef that we were just like hippies
there anyway it was fine and it was just
and then other people were doing the
same and now I have that people every
time I move into a new place I go and
buy a table from somewhere and I just
take the legs or cut the legs off yes
very Japanese
where'd you get that table form and I'll
show them a video that's what I did so
those people now Instagram me to say so
there if you might go up huh there might
be a new field for this right the trauma
of the ground living population but so
you just squat around the dinner table
or sinister could we again we see one
breast position there's there's multiple
we're going to go further me later
because it helped you so I'm Ravel stuff
from my run but there's kneeling
positions there's positions called shin
boxes and you can just flip from one to
the next lack of mobility sessions so
rather than us can do yoga and doing
flexibility work we just ground live
because again I don't see
hunter-gatherers doing mobility work and
yoga but they're amazing specimens again
so it's what are they doing so you strip
it back are they grounded
okay so let's ground live and what's
been different is each child that's been
growing for some Lola was familiar with
city seating furniture sitting furniture
Millie was about to when we ditched the
furniture so for her it's not really in
moda there is kind of you know where
Tallulah was born without any furniture
in the home we carried her everywhere
she never got it never had a car seat
never had a stroller always in a carrier
we did no nappies with her so she had no
nappy you do that we just we have more
trust in that with dogs and cats we have
loads of trust in them right we get them
a litter trays and they poop in it and
then they're done with our babies we
keep them in nappies for four years man
it's like the most intelligent species
we perceive ourselves the most
intelligent species that we don't put
any trust in our babies and it's a
relationship between Katarina to start
with and the baby
Katarina's my wife by the way and and
and she built this amazing relationship
that whenever the baby would make a
signal she'd know the baby news to go
where Tallulah needed to go to the
toilet and then eventually that's then
passed on to all of us because we can
see her signals and given the chance
that innate ability because the babies
picking are they're listening to me how
they're listening to me the signal gets
stronger and the signal gets so strong
the baby knows are know to go to taller
and then eventually and I think that Tim
UPS you stood up super strong I boom not
a toddler not rolling around but strong
and then occasionally what we again we
lived out in the Sun so we had
terracotta tiles on the floors
occasionally should do a poop on the
floor but at 10 months already she was
going off grabbing a cloth and then
wiping up her mess you know it was just
simply just again another level that I
think I could see it in their movement
because obviously we removed the
furniture she was rock climbing at 12
months is like people were like what's
going on this night Charles insane and
barefoot running they can all barefoot
run they run over anything just like I
do and again it's not again it's just
their innate abilities I haven't I
haven't dumbed it down in a way you
haven't DMS domesticated their movement
I've always just nurtured it and instead
of saying get down from there I teach
them how to climb you know my fear
doesn't get in the way
katarina occasion you had it you know oh
my god they're really close to the edge
and I said no code we have to go to the
edge with them and we have to guide them
and explain things to them but don't hit
them with all what's near the edge
because guess what I'm gonna want to
know what's over the edge of someone he
acts like that do you
so Caterina's totally on board did you
meet her when you were already like well
on this path or you know like what's her
relationship with all the stuff that you
do I met Kathryn if she blew my mind
because I had a Pilates practice years
ago in a health club I've had a big
space and Pilates practitioners and and
then I had a separate perception it was
in the health club and then there was
the main reception of the health club so
every now and then I'd come out to my
reception check what was going on with a
diary and who was in and and then I
looked across and there was this
beautiful woman standing behind a desk
house ah my friend who's there like I've
gotta go ask her who she is you know and
he said I think she's new okay so
whenever I just said look hey um can you
go and get a piece of paper and a pen
and she was like okay I'll [ __ ] ops
you went and got a piece of paper and
pen I just came back said can you just
write your number down I'll take you out
and that was it and we went out to
dinner when I took her to this
while back now and I didn't know at the
time I took her to Goucher grill so I
took her to get to a grill and we sat on
cowhide chairs and ordered a ridiculous
steak as I was doing at that particular
time when was that eleven years ago and
she looked really uncomfortable and I
said okay she said yeah I'm a vegan so
then we got around it I ordered some
amazing caramelizing and mushrooms and a
dish and that was fine and we and and we
hit it off and it was amazing and then
over time I'd always said that Katarina
was far more connected than I was and I
was almost trying to get to a position
where she was so um she was heavily
influenced by yoga but there were things
going on with her in within our own
digests digestion through what I'd say
was a poor vegan diet at that time those
are grains and pulses and that was it
and guided by I think her student knife
she was studying psychology at the time
she's from Slovakia so she was
converting her master's in psychology
into a UK degree and was working behind
reception while studying and being a
nanny so she was like I was just in or
you know this is incredible and yeah as
I say I've always felt like I was I was
having tea I was trying to get to her
level
uh-huh yeah that's cool man well I got a
heavy dose of your movement expertise
when we're out on the trail and you know
I knew that you were a barefoot runner I
figured when I took you out in a Malibu
Creek State Park that you might wear
sandals though I couldn't wrap my head
around the fact that you were actually
gonna do it barefoot but you did it we
ran like six and a half miles or
something like that and there's a lot of
wide sandy trail but there was also
significant portions of it that are
almost like a dry creek bed where
there's not just boulders but tons of
tiny little sharp rocks and you just
gracefully ran
across all of that like in perfect form
I was amazed I was super impressed and
I'm just trying to keep up and I in in
tribute to you I put on my vivo perfect
which I will admit freely admit that I
don't wear that often and it was quite
an experience man it's pretty amazing
that you're able to do that well it's
again it's it's an experience I'm
experiencing but again I see it as a
it's a biological norm to me I would
hope if we look back you mean imagine
what's in our DNA right now you know my
crimes are my paternal line goes right
back to 270 thousand years in East
Africa so imagine the terrain I would
have been traversing at some stage the
most hostile environments and terrains
and you know we're developing these
incredible movers over that terrain yeah
we look at or Tim for instance right
ninja warrior or parkour legend or any
of these amazing athletes and yet we
would all been doing something of that
nature somewhere you know whether that's
arboreal in the trees from persistent
hunting or something along those tribes
we would have all been doing it so it's
not like I'm doing anything different
it's just over time I've managed to tune
into what is again what I see is an
innate ability to be able to run like
that and talking of stories starting out
I mean I was I was born one of the
longest babies in history and reading
hospital so much so there was not enough
room in the womb so I managed to create
this weird and wonderful shape by
talking my feet underneath my armpits in
the womb and so when I was born I was
born of a deformity so my feet were
completely turned and almost crippled in
a sense so I then had I think the first
12 weeks was then put into cast each
week they reshaped my feet and then put
me into plaster cast every week for the
first 12 weeks and then beyond that I
then had these leather boots with a
metal bar that run across and where
they'd prized my feet open and do the
bars up and that then continued that
they're like a it will have a boot and
you can see my feet that printed my feet
inside it's incredible so when I went
into that then there's there's the
I met with a trauma coach and they sat
down and said well if we go through
childbirth with you what's the first
thing that come up and I remember doing
this
I was curse aramony you know in the
ceremony I was asking about freedom and
freedom came up as this freedom in a
beautiful woman's voice and it's that
freedom is innate in all of us you know
again freedom like anything else is an
innate ability but we handed all this
stuff we could given this this this all
this materialism and it just takes our
freedoms away bit by bit by bit by bit
and that's like the domestication
process until we don't have anything
left and it's then it was it's up to the
parents responsibility to ensure that
with those things is there is an
attachment so and it was for me is to
understand not to become attached to
anything
and then suddenly these boots just
appear in my in my vision my boots for
this metal bar during the therapy
session or during the ayahuasca ceremony
that's the first part and then this
voice came and the thing is to me we
freedom it can be gone in a moment and
then the medicine wore off and I've been
sat there for two hours while everyone
else is in him Oscar ceremony and I
don't not to become attached to the
ayahuasca so that was my last ceremony
with that going back to the therapy
session I'm sitting there with a therapy
go right he says about the trauma what's
the first thing and it was the same boom
as the image of these boots that came up
immediately and so then it's almost like
the boots that then shaped me into what
I'm doing today and everything so in the
trauma itself there's all those
positives within trauma that we don't
really discuss you know that's super
interesting well taking it back you grew
up you grew up in the UK but not in
London right like you know in like a
village in a village called Langley yeah
Wow
yeah the middle of nowhere place in
Berkshire is it when we were growing up
there there's not a great deal going on
there and there's a lot of boredom going
on there so um yeah for me there were
moments in amongst that way we'd get out
into a little bit of nature that was
punctuated in a in an existence of a
kind
village with just a linear boxes you
know going from one knows we were saying
earlier going from one linear box to the
other and unfortunately I had parents
that were working really really hard my
dad had a business it was just wasn't
successful but put everything into it
and their favorite activity was TV and
you know so we used to basically sit
there and and be in front of a box and
majority of the time and no and I I need
to move on one of these people that just
has to move so hide what be close is
like ADHD I'll be tearing I'd be I need
to get out and do stuff and then my dad
be saying what's wrong with him why does
he have to keep tapping as if I wasn't
in the room so it's like weird position
then every now and then I I could get
out and we'd go to this place called on
the gravel pits it was like a wreck for
us and to get to it there's there's the
crazy intercity trains into cities lot
bullet trains and we'd go across a
bridge with that fingertips balancing on
the edge of it to get into this place
called the gravel pits and then it was
shoes off and it was doing exactly what
I'm doing today but that was probably
when I was at my most happiest it was my
escapism from that zoom existence but
that Zoo existence was still quite it
was trauma for me it was like it was
like I had I mean there was lots of
issues growing up for me you know I was
in him out of trouble with the police a
lot and it was really just signs of hey
I'm over here I'm suffering here I'm not
needy I probably you know Strad
difficulty sitting in a classroom right
like what was the school experience like
my school experience was terrible oh
yeah I spend lot of time looking out the
window and tapping and a lot of time on
the school roof so it was to figure out
how to get up the drainpipe so the
school roof and what park or today but
yeah just like kids running around crazy
and then we we had a there's you know
the feel must have sound Inbetweeners I
had seen that there's a tee there's a
head in it is called quick whose real
name is Greg Davis he's like he's a
comedian today but he was actually my
English teacher at school so well he's
his teaching method was this he'd have a
set of headphones on not you that you do
know
we had Walkmans then so we had a Walkman
and he Walkman on and his headphones on
his sit with his feet up on the desk and
we all be lettuce left to be crazy
that was my school that's probably good
for you both and my end the school that
closed down in the end it was closed
down because it was just really super
rough in a village and just really rough
like poor behavior right okay
yeah like gang your people going in told
up you could be sitting at your desk and
someone will be getting underneath the
desks with a compass and jabbing you in
the back of the legs and stuff let just
kids just left two kids suffering I
guess and then being left to just behave
how they want to behave environment and
so drugs and alcohol enter the equation
at some point yeah I think I I mean I
started smoking weed quite early we were
already at the age at 14 I think we were
smoking weed at school and going into
class stoned and just that was the
obvious and then alcohol came into the
scene very early I never really cast
myself as having a problem of alcohol
until I did us I did a big ceremony
where I smoked toad venom it's like this
Sonoran Desert toad Bufo variants of
that and it's like it's like a super
powerful dose of DMT is it five Meo DMT
so it's a strongest DMT experience there
is but natural again so it comes off the
back of this toad and they go out and
they collect the venom they draw on
glass sheets and then it's like
crystalline and it you smoking is a guy
that works with his neighbours harvey oh
he worked with me he's a doctor and
studied with all the traditional
tribesmen and then in that experience
after that I had no attachment after
there was no attachment I come out with
it and then it highlighted ah I don't
need to drink and then I realized I had
a problem with drink and it kind of went
into the role of highlighting like a
real show of all the things I'd
basically done in my life up until that
moment of these are the things that have
led you here and there is no good or bad
or anything within it they're just all
experiences but these are the things you
can do without mmm and it's kind of I
could leave everything and
was almost trippy because it was
selective in I can keep all these things
because these these are okay is great
for you but this stuff you need to leave
behind so again with al Qaeda didn't
realize I had a problem with it and I
was in the military and it was quite the
norm there so people were just right
very boozy and again it was people
suffering so people dealt with this
suffering and to remove suffering we we
use drugs or we use alcohol in this
modern world we are today in the I think
the Army's full of suffering right
there's a lot of kids that probably had
the same upbringing as I did that
migrated to the Army because it's a form
of escapism yes so your decision to join
the army was that just like look this is
the only way that this is the only path
for me what was the thought process and
enlisting I think it was a few I think
one of them is I mean no I didn't hear
that much for a relationship my dad
because he was very much out at home
working running a business and we used
to see him probably on Sundays and if we
did it's kind of dipping in and out
because he's really stressed angry
frustrated at the world nothing's
working out and it wasn't the best
example I would say of masculine you
know for me anyway and I found myself
one of my uncles called us latchkey kids
where my parents are just so loose you
just just drift in and out and I just
found myself in there the wrong tribe of
people so I again with drugs and with
alcohol and then the drugs turned from
just weed into doing cocaine and ecstasy
and LSD and we've literally tried
everything and then but again removing
suffering I think it's not understanding
what is the suffering I think to begin
with and then the army came along I just
think it was just it was almost like a
savior at that moment if you if you
don't go and do this who knows what the
path is gonna be alright so like some
even unconscious drive to get some
discipline into your life yeah I think
it also just did just wanting some kind
of tribe and I probably think a
masculine tribe some think that rather
than me going out joyriding cars and
smoking weed and just getting in trouble
constantly and please turning up at the
house I need to figure out how am I
gonna get out of this and I had a cousin
who was in the
F at the time and then my dad said why
do you know why do you think about doing
the RSI I tried to get in the RAF no I
went in for the RAF recruitment center I
was already in a I joined the Air Cadets
funny how if we were in Air Cadets and
that was a that was on a school grounds
and they were called to four to four
squadron and that highlighted it for me
so then that gave me an opportunity we
were camping we were going out shooting
rifles flying gliders and things like
that that again it may enable me to tap
into what I loved most
when I was growing up in that village
and I could get to the wreck it was
supporting that so as I've been able to
me to get out and explore my physicality
and make a connection to nature again I
guess so then I could see that could
happen I had the army and I loved all
the physical side but I loved all the
assault courses and stuff like that so
after going into the recruitment center
the RAF they just said oh you're too
young come back in a year's time but the
army recruitment was next door servicing
like an obvious thing for me so off I
went I just knocked on the door and at
that time waiting yeah yeah we need we
need people for the RLC which the raw
logistics call and we're looking for
driver radio operators said men I got to
have Mike and earphones and learn code
and stuff like that and have a five
seconds life expectancy of war if I went
to my own and I did well I was then
there for a period of time in a holding
unit and in the holding unit again
everything about it up until that point
was amazing cuz I get I really got to
explore the physicality I loved every
part of it just the assault courses as I
say earlier and going out and exercise
and it was great was feeding me and
there was that again it was a tribe it
was like it's like a rite of passage
exactly but is this when you understand
it post that looking back when you
realize it's a pseudo right passage I've
gone to prison or something on that
there pseudo rites of passage is a rite
of passage and it enables you to them
view everything differently again but
there's an element of of such
conditioning that goes in there and I
would go home every now and then because
I was posted it was so close to me so
every now and then I dip in and out at
the same behavior so the rave scene was
on this scene right so we were out and
then eventually I found hard
clubbing and then we were popping pills
and doing trips and stuff like that and
then I'd go back into the army and it
was like and I remember reading in the
papers at that time and it said I'm
stoned up to their teeth and armed out
their brains right I owned up to 30 and
stayed out of the brain story and then
they had these compulsory drug testing
wagons would come around the military
bases I was like wow man this is TAF
this is I don't know I try again trying
to separate living in two worlds almost
and then I had I had a car accident and
we were basically meant to be on base
and I saved every bit of money I had for
this car it was not my pride and joy
meant now I could go back and I could
still connect to this world so it was
everything to me I think the car at that
moment and we weren't meant to be off
base but we knew the guy on the gates
who were gonna go car for the people we
drive into the town we rock up in the
town and on the way back to the base I
overtake like a parcel delivery van and
I see the guy he basically jumps into
the van from the sliding door on the
side gets behind the wheel and just
accelerates but that time I've already
just started overtaking but he just
turns right and hits the back of my car
flips my car over and we slide like a
hundred feet on the roof I put my hand
through the true the sunroof and cut
through my fingers and then it's all a
blur after that and the next thing I
find myself in the hospital and then
from the hospital and then told that I
nearly hit a woman with a pram that I'm
looking at being charged because it was
seen as my fault but all I've done his
over take a van and the Vans turned but
it was just the witnesses and everyone
around it so I and then I was a MIDI
back at the base and instead of dealing
with the trauma of having a car accident
and the fact of nearly hit woman of a
pram I got pin Jo so immediately the
response was let's put the guy in jail
and and how there are other people in
your car though right well yeah we heard
they were all fine nothing wrong with
you and so on you were kind of AWOL
also we were basically able just for a
matter of hours like four hours but yeah
we were able yeah absent without leave
you know so that was the way it was
treated regardless of the fact about a
car accident regardless of the factor
meaning fight this woman now I'm still a
well you've hit the nail on the head
that's not huh and that's the way it's
treated so off the back of that I just
lift lift lift a really bad taste in my
mouth and I was traumatized by the
accident but Carl's written off is all
this stuff around it and I it just
changed my perception of the army in
that moment you know it was done in what
way so you were just I need to get out
of here yeah it was like it was like
someone had lifted this lifted this veil
and it's like oh my god all the
brainwashing everything that's gone in
all the conditioning was all gone and
I'm left in this space like oh my god
what am I doing here
and what did that feel like terrible man
it was like again it was just supporting
again the need to want to get back to
this relationship over here so I'd find
myself back into the same group of
people who do the same behavior and then
it was a matter of getting out the army
so it took me a year if that kind of
feeling of being lost in this world but
probably even more lost over here
aha so how do you see your way through
that I guess again
dealing with the way that I would
normally dealt with suffering which was
to do drugs and alcohol that's what I
was doing mm-hmm you know that was
supporting it and and I I feel again
once I could work out what what is what
is the suffering it took me that period
of time to get there I feel but that
wasn't it you know it didn't end there
so I'd find myself in and out of trouble
again same relationship the police so
I'd almost go from one form of her
Majesty's service to another ones you
know I mean it was just like an
impossible journey and how do I get
myself out of this and a family member
said look you're in amazing shape and I
was body building all right sighs I got
to about I think was about 13 a stone at
one point and they just look one why
don't you just go and become a personal
trainer why you just so you thought
about that you loved the physical side
of things you loved training and it
keeps you on the straight narrow one you
just want have you thought about it so
just went and did an intensive I did
like a quick one month intensive
personal training qualification got my
not level 1 level 2 level 3 PT uh-huh
and are you in London at this boy
or nah I'm back at my back in the
village where village my parents my well
solving the guilt and the shame never in
early 20s you're jacked up you're high
and looking for a fight
yeah not realizing the fights inside of
course that's where it really is and so
I I take up this person training
qualification and this cousin said that
I've got this gig and it's um it was a
metal trading company called Mara Haden
at the time and it's in Knightsbridge
anyways he's got this idea of setting me
up with it didn't didn't manifest
straightaway but it was just I've got
this gig I think I think it will suit
you I find myself in a place in beckons
field which is another village outside
where I'm for not 12 and off miles so
it's the cycle in 12 miles it's a
personal training studio the client base
were women really around 40 plus their
husbands are making money in the city
and it was on that commuter belt outside
so they're interested in they're not
into bodybuilding they might like
looking at the jacked-up 20-something
trainer but yeah it was a very different
method training at that stage so the
woman who was running it Linda Mosley
she was training Premiership footballers
and it was very much about core
stability no he talked about core
stability earlier and he was like and
then Swiss boobs wort and then foam
rollers but and then all this stuff was
coming for but there was no resistance
machines which I love so it meant y-you
really had to work at giving someone a
training session and then out of that
working with core stability I found
Pilates and someone else said okay I've
got this Pilates studio you thought
about Pilates so I had this thing in
London going on Mara hade and Pilates
I'm working in this space over here and
so now I think I'm really interest in
this stuff and it brought on this
absorbant moment for me where I was just
sucking up information I was loving it
and it made perfect sense to me and I
and then within this space in beckons
field the woman to salute your greater
this staff and we're not going to put
you on a payroll we want you just
freelance and it would be an incentive
you to get more clients and so I built
up a big business in there Wow and then
in a short window of time as well it was
just something that I could I gravitated
wards and it made sense
and then pilates came along so I learned
34 positions and that work by Joseph
Pilates but Joseph Pilates was a radical
dude but he's primary the Pilates primer
so that was returned to life through
control ology and he had a whole
philosophy so even standing it would be
about getting the weight on the balls of
the feet so the BOF which is the same as
we're discussing earlier was about how
your posture would be aligned for
standing but you know he was an internee
in the war and so he fled went to New
York he got on a ship from Germany when
they asked him roll him in the German
police and off he went and he met his
what was the white what was to be his
wife Clara and she had a she was a nurse
so she gave some kudos to the fact there
was a qualification their medical
qualification and he set up his first
studio but the New York City Ballet so
then I think it changed it suddenly
become there was a lot of rehab for
dancers within that and so a you a
dancer Maya dancer so for me it kind of
I think it lost a little bit within
there's like a repertoire 650 movements
that you can learn within Pilates and
what I started to do was select specific
patterns would be appropriate for
standing that we could use for running
and all those things so I started to it
was like prescription for Pilates really
what I was getting into and then I start
to do like an apprenticeship in London
and I was doing this I'd work over this
space for a period of time you know and
I get into London for a couple of days
and took on the whole Pilates philosophy
of equipment based Pilates and Rehab
Pilates working with Reformers and and
the trapeze and stuff the Cadillac
trapeze and stuff like that and a chair
they went to share and then this Mara
Haden gig came up and it just changed my
life because I suddenly found myself in
this gym space and I only had to train
the three guys that that owned the space
it's like three traders and they hardly
wanted to train it was like bizarre so
they were paying me a ridiculous amount
money just to sit in this space three
days a week and it just meant I could
just suck up information so just
absorbing more and more around my craft
and then the occasional hour thrown in
that I'd have to train these guys and
then they really look after you like
take out two lunches and I wasn't a
single thing where you had to pay for
and yet just open my eyes a bit to
London
like this pretty cush it was pretty
situation yeah so why not just ride that
out whoa and then you know it's just the
call of the Pilate charlie cousin
running a Pilates studio you should come
over have a look at you huh and so I was
doing more and more in that space and
then I became full-time in there and I
loved it made sense to me it made sense
if I could prescribe it you know rather
than it be the set repertoire of
movements and you go for a routine it
was more like okay there's that there's
a way of rehabbing someone there's a way
of looking for specific posture types
let's say you could be a head chase or a
pelvis chaser or have a lordosis and you
could iron out and figure out is it was
almost like a system theory in a way you
could really see it and I think maybe my
dad's engineering background came in I
could just analyze things differently
and it just made sense what is the core
idea behind Pilates well he's a regional
thing was I in ten sessions you've feel
the difference in 20 you see the
difference in him 30 year old Abadi the
core thing around it again there was a
philosophy in there which was about
returning people back to what I would
serve as a biological norm again how
they should be moving standing and there
being this feeling of rehab behind it as
well so I could again you could look at
postural types and then iron out the
areas where they most needed it but I
think the floor almost and still today
is that it's like this generational
amnesia I think Peter can cause
environmental generation amnesia that
we've talked about running coaching
earlier you know if Arthur Lydiard model
from the 50s and 60s it's very different
to where today try and put the same
discipline through someone that's from
the 50s 60s the physiology can't cope it
breaks down because we're living going
back to the conversation we start with
which is a sedentary lifestyle so for me
the same thing happen with Pilates I
feared it it got to a point with me
where I felt people were rocking up to
do reformer workouts and trapeze
workouts and wanting to get stronger in
their core but yet they on the way out
they put the same compromising shoes on
and go and sit in the same compromising
chair to drive their car back to sit at
the same compromising dinner table in
the evening to get up and repeat the
same process again so I had to look into
always again it's everything outside the
studio really that counts you know yeah
you have to telescope out and look you
were starting to see things more
holistically and that's it a stick
approach actually Julie
my wife has gotten really into Pilates
which I never would have expected she's
always been a yoga person yeah and I was
telling you before how we're splitting
our time downtown and there's this
amazing yoga / Pilates studio right
across the street from our apartment and
she's been going in there and she's just
like had a transformation well she's
gotten super strong she's really into it
and she keeps telling me like you got to
go in and do it I just haven't that time
I but I really want to check it out I've
never done it before I've never explored
that methodology yeah I am I just found
out of love of it I found out of love of
it because I understood eventually that
what the biomechanics should be and what
the shapes that we should be making due
to the forces that are out there you
know so so explain that so I met this
guy like with Nicholas Romanov who's a
he was a track and field coach in the
Soviet era
he said he designed something called the
pose method and it's what we were kind
of discovering earlier we were running
so he discovered there's a specific
posture that everyone goes to when they
run and it's almost like there was
standing on one leg like you were
hopping on one leg earlier and provided
you hit that posture it means you can
deal with the external forces and
correctly create the appropriate shape
to do with the forces and this is
kinetics being the study of the forces
in kinematics is the shapes you make to
to the forces essentially biomechanics
so we train muscles and tendons and
stuff like that but really they're just
almost like a slave to that system and
given the right shape the muscles and
tendons know what to do and what we tend
to do which can come in with Pilates is
we train the muscles and the tendons and
we train the muscular activity which is
like bodybuilding in way we train
muscles for aesthetics or just to make a
stronger
but really we don't understand this
whole system is that those muscles and
tenders should understand their role and
you can't remove a hamstring just work
specifically on a hamstring then insert
it again and mail and expect it to
understand its role within the whole
organism so we've posed it was about
basically understanding these influences
with nature
the appropriate posture would mean the
appropriate shape which mean you can
deal with the forces appropriately lots
of appropriate yeah and so it then
applies to everything it applies to any
movement that I could look at I could
analyze and say right ok that's that you
could be more efficient if you just did
that you could be more efficient if you
did that and you remove the risk of
injury and once I discovered that it
didn't make sense to teach Pilates
anymore right it made sense to teach the
appropriate postures for things and then
almost find the micro elements of those
macro postures the things that running
for instance is a macro skill what are
the micro elements of that macro skill
do I need to get physically stronger and
improve the technique I understand the
kind of umbrella philosophy behind this
I think but I'm trying to wrap my head
around how that becomes teachable like
how do you break that down into specific
things that you can have people do to
work on well again I would look at right
what makes it what makes the wild
posture that you would need for running
how do I achieve that so I then now know
I looked at again the best runners in
the world what is it they're doing
they're not sitting in chairs they live
on the ground there's ground rest
positions so we could say the squat is
probably one of the prime positions to
be able to get into if you want to know
how to stand because observing all my
kids and observing Tallulah growing she
had to do all these amazing little rest
positions on the ground to get to a
squat once she could squat she could
stand up so when you suggest just to be
clear when you say squat you're not
talking about squatting in the gym
you're talking about just
literally squatting on the ground like a
rest position yeah flat-footed
completely rested with an appropriate
good shape a good posture and so that
the anchors aren't compromised the knees
on compromise the hip top compromised
and once you have that then then I would
say then you then you can stand and I
see people that go into multiple
disciplines and this could be a lot of
Yogi's that I see martial artists that I
see boxes that I see runners that I see
just athletes that can't perform the
squat and we have to look at right how
old is yoga right how old are these
martial arts so again if we look at that
generation generation I mean easier
model is we know that in those original
disciplines those guys weren't sitting
in furniture they were ground living
they were performing amazing things on
the ground and amazing squats there for
their ankle their knee and their hip can
deal with the ranges and the forces we
put through it so the modern Western
body if we shove yoga into it and the
martial arts and there isn't the ankle
the knee or the hip functions we end up
with a lot of knee injuries and low back
injuries and it's torsion in the knee is
one of the most compromising ones I see
with Yogi's that have been in a standard
for many many years but it's a simple
fix again I'll just take them back to
the ground and we go through ground
positions and get them back into
squatting and then once they have that
then again they have the appropriate
shape and then they're away because then
back I can to get re yes so what is it
that the squatting teaches the body
provided you have the the right foot
shape so there's a micro element of
squatting but the squat will teach the
probe the the dorsiflexion you need in
your ankle like the appropriate angle
angle in the ankle here which will then
create like a neutral ankle and new
triangle will create like a neutral knee
position and then you can have hip
mobility so it teaches this that the
foot then becomes a stable foundation
the ankle becomes mobile the knee
becomes stable the hips become mobile
and then that's that's the true
relationship of the joint actions and
then you have a stable pelvis and a
lower back so just by squatting it's
almost
like a wild state of nature's cure about
resetting your posture so even from a
run or our sitting at the desk is always
just take it back to the squat right
reset things before walking off even so
if you were going to pull out a
prescription pad and write a
prescription for me short of getting rid
of all the chairs in my house and
knowing me as a runner in a multi-sport
athlete
what is the prescription around
squatting or other things that I could
be doing or somebody who is like me
could be doing there's many people like
you I get cou I wouldn't I wouldn't goes
extreme to taking a furniture away it
would be too much don't worry it's not
your family wouldn't handle it
it'd be too much for most chill out key
into it I don't know I think again you
have to take it back to say oh after a
certain amount of time like after this
immediately after I'll be taking things
to the ground again just because the
length of time you're sat here I feel
bad that we're not sitting on the ground
so vodka because again we can squat
often that's the beauty of it like I I
was on a flight for 11 and a half hours
right and I'd get up I'd get up
regularly go to the back of the plane do
the mobility sequence open my hips up do
some shoulder mobility squat you know I
saw that on Instagram and then I hope
you out an aisle seat and then I'd go
back to the sea no I managed to get
extra legroom and I had a window seat
you did you have to climb over somebody
every time you wanted to get up every 20
minutes yeah and I was explaining
earlier the lady next moves really
demonstrating the you know the behavior
has encouraged me even more so um yeah I
would I would again just look at what
you're doing within the environment and
try and make small changes within it
rather than add too much to your day and
I think that's where a lot of things
fall down is we think I'll where am I
gonna find the time to do that so it's
very simple to be able to slide a chair
away hold the edge of the desk do a few
squats lifting your chest up and use the
desk as an anterior support a lot of
people I see don't just don't have the
ankle function ankle mobility to perform
a squat so allow the heel to come up and
just keep the shape and just drop on
your haunches
so it's almost like a straight body your
butt will be resting on your heel and
your knees will be forward you just a
few rhythm
or bounces in that position then stand
again and then you're ready to walk
other disciplines that we can agree will
cover just go through a few kneeling
positions that you can do on the ground
and a little mobility sequence that you
can play with within that and again
they're just rest positions like long
sits or straddle suits and things like
that the other thing for the upper body
is I recommend everyone to do is is put
a bar up to hang off so hanging is even
more ancient if you think them running
right so it goes back into what would be
our primate foundation so say if we were
primates for say 35 million years
hominids for hominins for 6 million
years and then hunter-gatherers per say
400 thousand years and then farmers for
ten thousand years and then the last
hundred fifty years do humans and there
were in this like human laboratory
experiments we're like lab rats now but
so if we go right down climb down that
phylogenetic tree we get to the
brachiating Apes to how to restore and
open up the ribcage and open up the
lungs would be to basically just hang
simple hanging systems due to being a
Venice Beach we get to do a fair bit of
them yeah there's plenty of art down
there so you go through different
hanging positions and we have in the
wrist the elbow the shoulder and your
scapula your shoulder blade we have all
the same brachiation brachiating
abilities as all the other apes and I
find people just some people have
trouble changing light bulbs now so it's
really important to just keep nourishing
that age of center shoulder injuries I'd
say is through the lack of brachiation
and then we try and do things like dips
in the gym but the scapular is
internally rotated and raised then again
it's just blowing up the shoulder so
hanging will help reset all straight arm
strength forget about bent arm strength
forget about pulling patterns just get
used to being completely straight in the
arm then your posture hang from it again
that will help mobilize the shoulder but
it will also open up the tendons the
ligaments everything and even the
arteries through that pathway you'll
lift your rib cage which will then make
your breathing clearer and then you can
play once you're in that position you
can start to go through active hangs so
trying to keep your arms straight whilst
lifting your chest up into your hands so
there's no bend in the elbow and that
starts to strengthen the lower trapezius
which is in the mid back a lot of the
disciplines that we see are about
mobilization and flex
and you can do all the flexibility
training you like you can do amazing
work for the mid-back but if you don't
have the strength to hold it there for
the lower trapezius gravity is going to
take over what about doing pull-ups and
chin-ups and great nose are pulling that
great but on a straight arm strength to
begin with
so there's IDO closer so he is a he's
like a hanging tutorial thing and I
would I would suggest that you basically
set a timer so you can have a time I
work with clients they start might start
with 10 minutes hang ten seconds hanging
and then they're off the bar and then I
give them 30 seconds rest then they go
back up and then that goes to 10 to 20
seconds 30 seconds and a minute and the
way this this then starts to unravel is
you start to build a relationship it
becomes a new habit so I'll give you an
example of someone who I coaches 78 he's
a guy called yahoodi he rocked up at my
gym door when he was 72 so six years ago
and he was completely stooped scrunched
up old posture
he brought natural birthing into the UK
wrote a book called boom birth and
Beyond - real manual for childbirth
amazing guy but gravity and age were
taking over and said what do you want to
learn how to walk okay
so it was a good place to skate off on
the treadmill and so at the age of 72
you want to learn how to walk so I
interesting right so what people up he
went on the treadmill just recorded him
showed him his posture oh my god I can't
believe I took like that you know bent
over and these are these boxes that was
introduced by a coach called Li and
basically of like the it's the conscious
competency model so I showed them the
video and up until I record them up
until that point they're unconsciously
incompetent and now I showed in the
video and now they're consciously
incompetent and then I go through the
drills they need and then they become
consciously competent and then over time
doing the same drills and the same
method which we're going to what you're
wanting me to break down what would I do
that then becomes unconsciously
competent and that's how you learn the
skill but remembering the next time you
get recorded you still be unconsciously
incompetent so you keep feeding that so
he he
you just wanted to learn how to walk we
go through walking go through that model
with him and I prescribed footwork for
rewilding the feet how to get the feet
in the foot shape rather than a shoe
shape so his feet were compromised by 72
years of inappropriate Footwear that
were compromising the shape of the foot
get that back then ground rest positions
so we then went through the various
different ground positions what I would
prescribe for him and then hanging and
that was it and then he had a hanging
bar in his home so this guy now since
then has climbed Everest base camp
Boutin Mount Kenya Atlas Mountains and
and basically this is his morning
routine so he wakes up now and in air
purified room trots downstairs gets to
the office on the second floor hangs on
the bar goes into the office gets on the
map does his mobility sequence has a
standing desks answers his emails go
downstairs perhaps his smoothie
prebiotics probiotics symbiotic Spurs
his vivos on walks down to the tube gets
to the tube he doors open he gets on
people usually say because he's 78 would
you like to see his uh now I'm okay
enough he goes he hangs on the bass he
hangs on the bars while the tubes moving
two feet off the floor tube stops doors
open right next one next time it doors
closed any squats and he squats and then
he does breath work so he does between
breath work hanging squatting in a bit
surfing so surfing you don't hold on to
anything you just try and get your
support on the train and that's at the
age of 78 he just made small changes all
the way long and he's using his commute
he's in a red average age now you know
and his spine straightened down later
now it's completely upright Wow but look
so the difference is how yet how he
looks now so he doesn't look like the 72
year old he looks you know he looks
great he looks an amazing shape and he's
a newfound confidence within it it's
kind of a beautiful act of humility to
walk into your gym and say teach me how
to walk to I think that takes courage
most people wouldn't do that
and it's interesting to think about
walking as something that we might have
to learn or relearn like we were talking
about this in the context of running
like born to run we're all
born runners we don't think that we need
any instruction it's all instinctual and
intuitive and I suppose on some level it
is but through the means by which we
live our lives in this Western
industrialized society we've reshaped
our bodies that have now created a
situation in which we probably do need
to formally learn how to run and you
just pointed it out to me when we're out
on the trail like all these things that
I'm not doing correctly but I could be
doing better because I'm unconsciously
incompetent in certain aspects of what I
do even though I've been doing it for a
long time and I've done it at a decent
level Yemen ready decent level but
there's still so much to learn you know
and I know and I know I know that I'm
not you know working at my capacity
because I've never had anybody formally
instruct me in anything well something's
different yeah and we were talking about
the similarities between swimming and
running swimming is is something that is
more technique non intuitive like you
really do have to learn it and if you
learn it at a young age and you learn it
from somebody who really knows what
they're doing and you dedicate yourself
to honing that technique then it becomes
a situation in which you are
unconsciously confident like I don't
think about it but I'm always working on
my stroke and my technique and when I
see when I go to the pool and I see
other people swimming it's just alarming
to me how bad most people's technique is
and how unwilling they are to address it
or deal with it because they're more
concerned with their fitness they have a
certain amount of time they just want to
get make sure that they get their heart
rate up and they don't want to step down
off you know the pedestal and kind of
build a new foundation and that's
something you were talking about with
running like if you're doing it
incorrectly you really do have to hit
pause and start over with like okay how
do you stand up how do you squat how do
you stand on one leg
like how do you jump up and down before
we can even get to how you're gonna
carry your body when you run yeah I've
hit the nail on the head about you know
with coaching is if you want to play
golf you you get a you get a coach yeah
you know you want to play tennis you get
a coach swim you want you get a coach
yeah I I think of I think of a swim
stroke is very much like a golf stroke
people spend their whole lives trying to
perfect their golf stroke I think he can
do that with swimming it's less
intuitive to think that that would be
required and running but the more I
learned the more I realize it's no
different yeah does like explaining
early you know there's that box isn't
there that the Pope Nicholas taught me
this there's the skill when this could
be anything so you can put running in
the box as the skill and then underneath
that skill you have these three pillars
the one is technique one is the mind one
is a physiology you know so you without
the technique unfortunate its over time
the physiology can break down you know
so if you could just keep working on
technique over time physiology in the
mind will just get stronger with the
discipline anyway there's strength
conditioning you can do around it and
that's only feeding the strength of the
technique and the shape that you might
do to the forces again but I think the
problem is as humans when we're working
on technique we don't feel like we're
making progress
because it's so I think you know it's
it's then from a coaching perspective
it's it's trying to find things that
they can you can keep uploading to the
run like I was saying earlier realm the
stripping it right back you have that
amazing bit of concrete here by the pool
is to do certain jumping drills and
things that will just keep feeding the
shape and then you just go for your run
and you just keep doing these drills and
that will just keep feeding into the run
and it will enable you to just think
even on the heals those little cues on
the hillier enough to go our posture
build tiny pulling actions they will
just make you lighter on the run as
Ronin and the senses and the feeling and
the hearing you know bring those into
the run as well but it's again it is
about stripping it back you know saying
only off work with fell runners and to
explain to fell runners you're killing
it with mileage right ah you know guys
you're injured we need to take things
back you know it's easy I mean people
can wrap their head around like look you
gotta run 100 miles a week like yeah no
problem I'll go do that but you tell
them look you got to stop what you're
doing and you got
like I'm not doing that yeah exactly and
keep filled with finding that posture
but without it somewhere sigh I think my
one of them I just said how long do you
want to run for how long you want to
keep running full well I always want to
keep running I said well you if it's the
long game in longevity we need to stop
and we need to do this because that will
enable you to keep running forever but
in your current state of what you're
doing how many times you wake up the
next day and you've got an eagle or an
injury you know again going back to that
everyone model evolutionary model is if
we if that was the case for persistent
hunters we probably won't be here you
know I mean I know I can't I can't go I
can't do that today
I've got bit run as an Eeyore I've got
Achilles tendinitis plantar fasciitis
all my backs out you know so it's we we
have to then say well okay what is it on
doing what is it I'm doing that's then
leading to the Neagle because then
Nature's Way of punishing you for that
that poor level of skill is the tweak
the injury or disease right yeah because
it's not just running it's there's a
natural way of doing things you know
which is a holistic approach that we
look at and the closer I can get to what
is the biological norm the less likely
the injury the disease that yeah so
there's a lot of runners that listen to
this and I'm interested in trying to you
know provide people with practical
takeaways so let's start with some of
the main things that you see when you
see see when you we need to see people
out running like it must be glaring to
you like oh my god they're doing this
wrong they're doing that wrong like what
are the common mistakes that most
runners are making that are easily
rectified through a few simple things to
think about in practice posture so head
position so the heads are huge weight so
you find five point five kilos of weight
if the head is position is too far
forward then you have to overstride you
have to land way ahead of your body or
your hip alignment otherwise you'd
faceplant the pavement
so if your foot isn't there underneath
the head you'd fall over so if you try
and firstly just keep the head up above
you thinking that you're looking ahead
not down at the ground and always
looking almost down the end of the trail
because it you can see you can visualize
the whole trail if I run with my head
down I can only see a short part of the
trail and also have to react off
everything if I keep my head off my
chest up I can see everything and I can
make these I can trust that an eighth
system to make the calculations of what
it needs to do and if your head is down
and that's thrusting your hips backward
hips full backwards yeah so you create
like a K shape and that K shape means
that the chances are you gonna be
landing on your heel and it's it's the
more line of walking that posture you
know there's a heel striking walking
then we roll through the foot to the big
toe and then you have a pendulum effect
of the leg it swings to the next heel
through to the big toe and running as we
went through earlier is more like a
series of jumps each almost like you're
jumping on learn to jump on two feet
first weaving it with a with an upright
posture so it's a great little tool that
for everyone is to keep head up your
chest up and your pelvis and imagine a
plumb line so there's so I'm run a line
through your body or even set up their
iPhones great for that just get a an app
called coaches I and with coaches I you
can set it up and pro profile and record
yourself and then you can draw a fancy
lines on it so you can draw a plumb line
it's really called out of that and so
you can draw a line and you'll see where
your head is in relation to your hips
imagine you wanted your head your chest
your head and then the foot you're
landing on all in one line yeah and then
that's jumping on two feet and then try
and keep that line going and there's a
nice little rhythm to it like
ding-ding-ding and try and land
flat-footed not on the balls your feet
not on your heels but try and get
completely flat in your feet and then
just repeat that and go you know just
choose a length like a strip we had
earlier or ten meters you could talk ten
minutes and come back again and then
jump on one leg so hop on one foot and
again trying to find that same flat
footed landing with the same shape and
have the other leg pulled underneath you
so your ankle is almost directly
underneath your hip and your knee is
slightly forward right and then repeat
the same process jumping because running
is a series of single legged hops
hops so hop on one leg so we just jump
on the one leg and then you turn you
come back again on the other leg and
then you can build a rather them in like
one two three four and then switch and
pull the other leg up so alternate
alternating positions and that gives you
an understanding that running is
actually there's a pulling cycling
running that's what your hamstrings are
there their hamstrings a huge pulling
muscle and it's role is to get that
ankle underneath your hip so you're not
driving your knees up you're thinking
about getting your ankles up I mean view
and they're just some simple postural
clues and then again just taking things
back to squatting so what do we see the
classic is that it's more like this head
head position being forward and
promoting a heel strike I think the
other thing is this world of footwear
and we discussed this earlier is for me
the more and more information I put
between me and the earth the more I dumb
down my senses and the more I dun down
my senses the less feedback I get the
less chance I have of dealing with the
forces and creating the right shape to
deal with those forces so it just dumbs
down the signal to your movement brain
to make the appropriate shape again you
are you're now able to just run barefoot
on all manner of surfaces but that
doesn't happen overnight right like how
long did it take you to kind of build up
to the place where you can handle that
kind of you know terrain under your feet
I guess again I think it goes back into
that original conversation about the
original trauma like when I was born and
my my mama so I just had incredibly
strong legs I just I was doing like
hamstring curls with this metal brace on
my feet lying on my front constantly
doing this and so for running for me
when I was in my first schools going in
I was ringing like 400 meter races by
200 meters as a young kid but I was
doing that better and we had a concrete
playground that we were running on I saw
run around that barefoot so I guess it
was already going in a very early age
that's crazy I love football barefoot
this all goes back to like anyway early
for you and then and then that then gets
put to one side and then this big chunk
of just craziness in between which is
dealing probably with
initial stuff that wasn't hot wasn't
dealt with the way it should have been I
guess but um and then and then when I
started with pose method I think at that
stage I then started to realize there
was a form I should say and then we met
vivo barefoot and then beaver Beth had a
shoe you know we got the shoe I was like
yeah but you need to technique about the
technique people are gonna be a nerd
wearing a shoe you know vivo in like the
very early days yeah they would call
Terra planner then so before they would
be bare foot so then it was then it then
it became more about rather than just
Nicholas's model of the posture we then
started to look at what about the feet
and so already I wouldn't wear anything
else after meeting vivo sunny become
very clear that I had to be a minimal
shoes and believe me we were like guinea
pigs people were looking at though my
shoes on your feet oh I know they were
like these really what massive wide toe
box is really white there were not clown
shoes basically they were proper clown
shoes and I was quite stylish up until
that point I was like once she won she
won is you won't turn back and I
couldn't because I knew too much why we
don't mess my feet up but you gotta like
why would I call the guys up in vivo
come on you gotta at least make these
things look a little and I guess that's
Jim but you know why would I compromise
my feet and I guess knowing that what it
was truly to have compromised feed you
know I mean it must have been that that
must be in there somewhere
and so then running and I started you
know just start doing my I just started
doing the mileage in vivos to start with
and then is that right okay well if that
feels that great and that's minimal
that's not three millimeters originally
and that meant that anything about three
minutes he was dumb down the information
you receive I then started retreats I
then take people through what was
barefoot running and I go through the
protocols of barefoot running and then
it got to the point right see that on
the run on there hmm
and then I guess it's a bit like whim
with breath work and the ice it suddenly
became this thing for me that ah that's
crazy doubt I but I know I can run on it
why go why is it I can run on it brain
and again it doesn't hurt and it just
got to this point where I'm just really
relaxed I'm just super relaxed and we
again we would have all been doing that
I'm not doing anything different what
we'd have been in doing at some stage
it's just my feet of now they've I've
rewilding my theory while did the
behavior one of one of the things I
noticed when we're out running was how
quiet your your feet were on the ground
and I'm running in the vivos you're
barefoot and my feet are just like you
know like I'm landing I'm such a heavy
foot you know and you were telling me
focus more on don't focus on like
landing the foot focus on the light
touch and then the pull upwards which I
had never really thought about before
yeah like there is no touch I even
thinking there is a ground I'm just
thinking about I've got to get I just
got to get my feet underneath me mm-hmm
so there's no recognition of ground it's
just off off off off off off off how
quickly can I get my feet off that great
yeah and there is a recognition I was I
was thinking about it and trying to work
on that and I still was landing like
really heavy footed like boom boom like
a clodhoppers but that's where again it
would working by the pool as I said
earlier you just keep working on just
the action of getting your feet on the
ground and honest really smooth surfaces
be barefoot yeah you know so how did you
like become this guy like we're still
you know we were kind of tracking this
chronologically for a minute we went off
on it you like you were the Pilates guy
for a while then you found who's the
rushing what's the name of the Roman oh
Romeo so you kind of you know start
falling under this philosophy but how do
you then you know kind of blossom into
you know the natural life stylist like
what's the in-between phase a big chunk
this you ready yeah so I go I've once I
discovered Nicholas his work I can't
have a studio a platitude anymore so I
closed the Pilates studio and I'm kind
of lost in a bit of limbo and a cousin
of mine Lee another guy Matt and myself
decide that we're gonna go into business
together because it's a great idea to go
into business for friends and fan
that's what we do right and we find this
disused railway building beautiful was
on the tube line it was a ticket hall
originally in West Hampstead back to
brick and it just was wow this is like a
1950's boxing mmm movie scene you know
we can let's let's open up a boxing gym
so off we went we flew to Pasadena in
Texas to train with this amazing boxing
coach who had something like 360 Golden
Glove winners he was a technical genius
in boxing very much like Nicolas is in
running we managed to discover one in
boxing and he blew our minds and he blew
our minds in the way that we could
suddenly take anyone and just put them
through these fundamentals of footwork
and timing and rhythm and turn lawyers
into excellent boxers hmm in a very
short window time and it just fed the
same thing what's the skill here's a
skill it's boxing there was a technique
here's the technique then we could build
the physiology in the mind exactly the
same as Nicholas's model that he didn't
know the language is to call it fiber
muscle and stuff like that which he
meant yeah tendon action he called it
fight the muscle winner and he could
pick apart any boxer and sudden you
realize because there's the real
technical box as the technical genius is
out there and I mentioned one owner
which is like Bernard Hopkins we could
talk about Mayweather and they're just
they've been doing it at such an early
age but they've been honing their
technique the whole time rather than it
just be raw talent and physiology
because that again doesn't it breaks
down and these guys get spanked over
time boxing is really ruthless like they
just suddenly shows people their age if
they haven't been working on technique
so we bring that back and we set up this
1950s style boxing club with a 1950s
style of boxing looks like a movie set
people want to hire it and we also had
this running model within it and then we
suddenly start to move in a different
tribe of natural in actual movement
influences like Oh minor core and this
company called wild Fitness and we bring
a model in that was then around how you
move naturally and was ito port all
around
no learn on the same for us at that
point so this was
I think 13 something like 13 years ago
perhaps maybe 14 years ago and we
basically we were almost ahead of the
time with natural movement which sounds
bizarre with natural moon we were ahead
of the time yeah we're ahead of the time
bringing this evolutionary model in and
ahead of it being like I'll psych ice
tea yeah and then people would come in
Riyadh Chris McDougall rock up from born
to run with plantar fasciitis injury
from doing the books and my cousin men's
thoughts his plantar fasciitis injury ow
yeah planner for that then explodes that
model and then we wait he had plantar
fasciitis after the book and I think it
came in I think he'd returned
I think his story was that he returned
back to wearing a conventional running
shoe or something after writing the book
no I think it's within the within it and
I think he gets plantar fasciitis in
there said my cousin leaned and fixes
his plantar fasciitis by going through
what we're talking about the posture and
the rhythm and the timing and then I
think he goes back into writing the book
and then he's then his fixed it was very
quick it was just a simple cueing
technique where he spent too long on the
ground easily done so it's not a fault
his running it's just I think it was
just going back to wearing a sneaker
with rubber which men he then spent too
long on the ground which means the plant
is over his foot can't understand its
tendon action so it gets stiff and then
you end over here so that that was
rocking around and then vivo barefoot
then off early a deal to be there before
unning coach so he lends his arm jumping
ship then my friend Matt who's a
strength conditioning coach and it was
an amazing strength and it got it bronze
in kettlebells at that time for the UK
credibly strong he's like you know this
isn't for me anymore I think I'm out and
unfortunately I'd inherited this crazy
position from my dad where I'd stay in
there and my ego got the better of me is
I can do that work I'm gonna make this
business work he was sitting on some
crazy lease crazy lease that the three
of us was struggling move and I took the
whole thing on but I had a really strong
coaching one-to-one business and then my
coaching one-to-one business kind of
paid for everything and then we had
members coming and using the space and
then over time the rent and the lease
were going up because we designed to
deal that way so it didn't matter what
member
were coming in it was always this I did
I'm gonna stay in now just like my dad
do with his business and his business
went down the pan and and then I saw his
breakdown and I saw it just turning to
just it was just a nightmare for all of
us and he was never the same being after
that but somehow I was going along this
path it was crazy and I was actually was
just observing myself doing it and but
couldn't get out of it but then we had
Lola we had loader and we had milli and
I need to this this I can't
what's going on and I remember I was
holding a workshop and I had personal
trainers Yogi's don't remember just a
room full of just very different people
and I'm teaching them about the
philosophy which is around a natural
lifestyle but I've got it under the
umbrella of natural movement and I'm
saying that there's a physical social
spiritual need needs and if then then we
have emotional well-being which then
annalistic approach so the closer I can
get my physical social and spiritual
needs to nature the more healthy the
organism is going to be yeah I'm this
guy you're living in dissonance with
that totally man and I and and this
train just went past the building as
we're on the tube line and the doors
went and I just had this just oh my god
I'm a fraud and it's like one of those
really deep deep moments but it's a
proper Epiphany and I'm looking at the
guys in the room moment you know and I
get through the workshop and one of the
guys who I've been working with in
Ireland for quite some time
really really influenced him along the
way and enabled him to go and open
studio said you're right and I said I
think I'm gonna close the gym man Wow
it's a giant closing within a month I'd
wrap things up but we lost everything
you know and went bankrupt had no money
and yet we had two kids a wife and yeah
but this is your divine moment yeah now
that like dismantling forced you to
confront yourself figure out what was
important yeah man I got to see
everything to see all the pain I've got
to see all the trauma everything all the
suffering all highlighted within a year
of trying to somehow get through a
breakdown and turn it back into a
breakthrough so I could rebuild tone
whatever time he is you know main is
that where the is this where the
ayahuasca comes in yeah I want to hear
about this you know this is like it's it
just it comes up with alarming
regularity like as somebody who's in
recovery for many years for drugs and
alcohol its I have this internal
dialogue around this like this internal
conflict about it because on the one
hand it's undeniable to me I know people
like yourself who have had these
experiences they're they're they're
better for it I can tell that it has
given them something that has enriched
their lives but at the same time if you
tell you know a drug addict that the
solution of their problems lies in a
mind-altering substance that's a very
dangerous tricky intoxicating thought to
plant in my mind and so it scares me at
the same time but I've talked to so many
people both on this podcast and Offutt
who've had really kind of incredible
experiences and I've had that Gabor maté
a on the show who is telling me like
this is something that could be helpful
with you know the addiction issues that
I struggle with so it's to be tabled I
sort of I'm interested in it but also
kind of cautious
yeah doubt it as well I think along my
path this year that I take and I think
it just again it highlighted the
suffering and then you understand the
suffering is one basically using
substance for to get away from instead
of really facing it mmm and and that's
also within the tribe of influence the
people that have influenced me and made
been anomie to get my first ten plates
in life so the first six years of life
that I've observed in my tribe I've then
learned to suffer within those first six
years somehow there's some kind of
emotional suffering there and then this
was an opportunity to suddenly I could
see all my tent plates and I could see
everyone's behaviour and I could see
okay
there's something not great here what is
it
what in the world is happening here
because I've done all the work I've
become this amazing physical specimen
right
I can move well I can do this I can do
that go around it's just a facade and so
I look at my physical self my social
self and then I realize I haven't been
doing any work over here in the
spiritual model you know what's my
connection over here and I suddenly
start researching and I find meditation
and I find breath works I'm playing with
those and then my wife's like yeah well
okay um we're here I know I'm properly
taking it I don't know I think I'm gonna
go to Peru and I think I'm gonna go and
um stay with a shaman you're gonna be
worse at this thing I was good keeps
popping up catch me I'm in the middle of
like you know we don't know how we're
gonna pay the bill yeah exactly and I'm
throwing that one out there and she's
like well okay um so what's going on I
said well just I've been researching it
three people in the same week I've been
researching it suddenly to send me a
message saying Tony of you heard about
this I I was good on first of all I
don't know how to pronounce you know I
wa you know so anyway I'm going off his
wife and I said look I'm 40 in a year's
time I think for my 40th birthday I'm
gonna base that you go and do I'm gonna
go and do this ceremony I'm gonna go to
Peru I think gives me plenty of time but
in the meantime I'd basically hired a I
was looking at hiring a friend's house
which was in the Cotswolds and I saw
that my same 40th birthday a birthday
yeah but would have meant the same
social tribe the same alcohol the same
drugs the same people yeah rockin up at
the same events I'm not to cancel this
thing I've got to explain to this couple
I'm not coming and they're friends of
mine right so just oh I'm sorry messing
you around I'm gonna cancel the house
I'm not gonna use it for the 40th and um
though I was going on Tony what's
happened not so I've got a different
kind of party yeah I just started I'm
gonna go to Peru now I'm gonna go I'm
gonna go and stay with shaman and Tony's
lying guy and they were like no you
don't need to do that no we've got a guy
he's here and we're doing a ceremony in
six weeks time at that at the same house
no someone else and then I quit but with
don't worry about it it's on us right
Wow and
you can you can you can come anyway in
between that period of time this guy
rocks up at my door and he's from LA and
he has of course foot injuries right
stuff going on his feet and he's it's
just in trauma around his feet I've
heard you're the guy to come to and so
we do two hours together this little guy
rocks up and it's got like ginger hair
in a ponytail when he arrives in the
room he's got a coffee and a cookie for
the guy and the guy says thanks man
and they just look each every knots and
the guy leaves and I say yeah I said
yeah it's just my driver says it's the
driver like okay just carry on the
session if nothing happened the guy
leaves another guy rocks up and he said
oh I've got your details and the guy's
just come in is their chance I can
squeeze an appointment from you he lives
in a beef of this guy so yeah yeah okay
so we do a session together we move
around for a bit so if you're ever
thinking about coming to ib4 let me know
I have a house and we can do a retreat
and since and I said yeah I've looked at
doing a retreat in a beef I found this
guy and they have an amazing house but I
just I'm just not ready to do it yet so
anyway six weeks fly by and I'm then
turn up at this house they give military
tell us of this house and it's down this
country lane and these electric gates
open up and it's like this mile long
drive go through this country estates
get this massive pad in the country and
I'm walking the first person I bump into
is the guy from Ibiza the guy with the
cookie noticed another castle is there'd
be four guy and he's the one who says oh
if you think about holding retreat come
over and then he introduced me through
another guy who turns out to be the
house that I was going to rent in I'd be
13 says two people was I all
coincidences right they're all there at
this space then I walk through and then
everyone's like are have you seemed so
and so's as the guy who owns the house
and they're like no no he's not very
well he's gone to bed and he's not
feeling very well and I'm not okay I'm
gonna go and crash off in a bit just
little bit edgy about the ceremony you
know there were nerves though it's my
first ceremony and I'm with all these
seasoned ayahuasca spiritual kale
drinkers and I'm thinking about going to
go to sleep I feel
in the morning wake up in the morning I
walk back into the house and they're
like ah sons this guy's up so I'll call
him s OS up he's awake in comes s and
he's the guy it's his house is the
little guy with the cambia and the
cookie is his space the driver
incredible right yeah so then the whole
thing was already it was set up around
it just felt like coincidences and there
are no coincidences it's all just
perfectly aligned then we go into a
ceremony the first ceremony I walk into
and I'm I am pretty nervous at this
point I'm kind of in a line with this
and then you have the shaman here and he
has this whole troupe of singers and
he's band with him and just the
performance alone I would recommend you
know they were incredible musicians
incredible songs all night and we drink
a first cup basically and you set an
intention going in and my intention to
go in was just to find honesty I think I
was looking for the term honesty and
then I just got to see in that first
ceremony a boy that it wasn't neither
man I got I got showing the boy the
innocence of the boy and I'm innocent
despite all this stuff I've done all the
trouble with the police we'll the drink
the alcohol the stress I've given anyone
in my life the poor decisions I've made
the stuff that I'm disgusted with to
this day I mean it was just oh
underneath it all you're just an
innocent boy you know you've just been
shaped that way it's the environment
that's done it but that's honesty you
know just and then got shown just me
behind this completely clear mirror but
it also highlighted lots of stuff around
my dad and my relationship I might add
and it was very much like um I've never
I'd never felt like I'd hugged my dad or
had that kind of relationship and this
voice was so clear and precise that it
was you know that's what he's inherited
but you're the position of change you
want to hug your dad why are you waiting
for him to argue
so immediately off the retreat that was
the first thing I did I went around to
their home and gave my dad a hug so that
was the first thing I could try and
think that's good rebuilding that
relationships have anything that's
probably the changing the pattern than
most that was the start I'd say from
that ceremony was the change in the
pattern then we did a second night and
in the second night was a bit more I
would say hallucinogenic for me I was
seeing sand crazy I was riding a lizard
at one point just on the lizard's back
yeah guy who's the shaman he's like the
head of the lizard and he's in stirrups
like this the band members are sat
behind him right and they're all playing
and I'm just like oh what's the lesson
here
yeah exactly what was on here it was
just like this nice and incredible ride
nice and and again just then I'd go and
I'd experience all these different doors
so the lizard was stopping I'd open a
door and it was showing me again like a
it was basically just highlighting all
this stuff I'd done in my life like a
movie set like I'm showing me real off
that real off the real like in Christmas
Carol
style that's kind of style but riding a
lizard right and the psychedelic crisp
but it's very interesting and and stuff
like on this thing when I was saying
earlier about my dad saying about why
does he keep tapping that came up for me
in a ceremony it was just I was writhing
around I can't sit still and in this
voice saying that I was a dragon baser
you're a dragon animal you know imagine
trying to sit still your dragon how the
[ __ ] you gonna sit still why does he
keep tapping you have to say why no I
why not I'm just I'm just I'm in this
cage you've imprisoned me in this thing
and I need to be able to move and then
so I started then after that ceremony it
highlighted I need to move more but not
through strength training more through
types of play and dance and try and
revive something and that came this
amazing movement of the lizard and I
realized the lizard wasn't a lizard at
all as a dragon so the take of the tech
all right so the takeaway from this
whole experience is you have this sort
of clarity or epiphany about this
direction that you want to take like
taking movement and translating it in a
way that you can teach and be of service
right like yeah this this lizard dragon
energy so it's in in certain respect
your your your crediting this experience
with providing you with that kind of
sensibility like that clarity of what to
do next
yeah I think it's just it highlights I
believe what you already know but it
just again strips back all the
conditioning I believe and enables you
to see things again through the the
honest pure eye of yourself mm-hmm
but the innocence within you without the
physiological armor or as I say
conditioning but that that's just dust
is one ceremony that was kind of a
moment in change I felt probably was it
was the start of something and then I
did I did another two ceremonies after
that and we've been each ceremony
something even more profound was
happening like the one that I discussed
about freedom right and then a friend of
mine a particular house said I just want
to show you a video and so he showed me
this video and I said what is it and he
said that's me and I said what and he's
on he's basically curled up on the
ground and he's just like chlorine at
the earth and screaming chlorine at the
earth and he's doing this crazy stuff
like it looks like he's throwing stuff
off of him and then eventually he stands
up and he's just like this roaring on
this primal roar of his chest shooting
up what is this and he's not I smoked
this man I was the toad energy smooth
this toad and he said um and I know this
guy I've worked with him from ahead of
time and he had this like closest in his
mid back so he had this quite strong
curvature and it didn't matter what we
did we do as much mobility work as many
theoretical extension things hanging
overhead squatting there was still this
bit that needed to unravel and so his
explanation of what's going on in the
video because there's some ones just
recording it is that he just the mount
inhaled he went off to this space and he
was just surrounded by tribesmen of
thousands of years all around him and
pinning him down on the ground and
holding him down and he was trying to
throw them off him and then he's clawing
at the earth and trying to make his way
out and then eventually he stands up and
he's thrown them all off and he's just
there roaring and they accept him into
the circle so he's had this amazing
masculine rite of passage at that stage
and before that he would have said he
had a prominent masculinity and it was
almost that's what he needed within the
exact moment that's what he got through
that ceremony and his back altered his
back altered in a 20 minute experience
with five Meo DMT it straightened out as
back straight now it's back and that's
where we always trim things and have a
physiological level we look at things
only on a physiological level and we
think we know yogi practice and we think
we know these things about the forms and
the postures but really in that real
deep spiritual component you can address
so much as well you know his physical
shape just change it was just
unbelievable so for me I just need to
know when I can do it how did you yeah
so you're here like give me the toad how
do you make sense of that experience and
the kind of three-dimensional you know
impact that it had like on his spine
like how do you hide Alma again do that
I think I see it in so I can I can only
coach you through one I know because I
don't personally work in that realm I
don't work with medicine so I can't
explain it from their side I can explain
it in stuff that I teach like play so I
was teaching at a big yoga Festival and
I was headlining so I was a speaker
coming in and then he wanted me to put
this session on so I rock up with my
guilt so I woke up with Lola and Millie
and today I think it's a pretty young
man and baby in the sling and I walk
into this what was a converted barn and
I go into the barn and I have to address
the the Yogi's who put all their mats
out everything really pristine and
they've lined everything out and they
put the cushions out and everything and
all the shoes are at the back and when I
said I'd hate to disappoint you or but
I'm not a yoga teacher I don't do yoga
but this festival was called yoga
Connect
um let's put yogurt one side I'm going
to teach you all about connect and how
to connect and how to find connection
through movement and play so I said if
you can unwrap your roll your mats back
up and put them to the back of the room
and then when you're done that just way
to meander around the room in any shape
any form and they're walking around the
room or different directions and then
they keep going give them two minutes
just to figure out what's going on and
just to calm a bit and that's right okay
now just do is just as you as you will
pass something where you take a direct
look in their eye and then I want you to
walk on again and then make eye contact
every person you pass make eye contact
and they make eye contact and then they
go around the room and I leave it
another a couple of minutes so just this
same practice I can always use brush
shoulders when you go past someone so
then they brush shoulders and then
laughter starts to come in already so
they start to make a connection already
and they're building already trusts and
they're starting to move as a collective
rather than a bunch of individuals
meandering around the room so the energy
changes and then my kids are in there
because they can feel the vibes changing
and the Energy's changed and it's now
not strict serious adults says play
coming in and then I ask them then to
hug when they walk past some once they
start hugging and then they go past now
to keep walking around room I'm and I
clap my hands I want you to say when I
say yoga you say Connect connects
they're like walking around the room
when I say you say connects and they
connects and then they were hugging and
just starts turning is this movement
festival right and then I then ask them
to then embrace lock heads forehead to
forehead make eye contact and now one of
them leads and the other one has to just
follow and they just start moving in
pairs around the room in different
shapes and different forms so rather
than what can become quite linear in
forms and strict postures you have to
find within yoga suddenly enable them to
start expressing that flexibility but
free play and what we got to see was
some incredible patterns and forms and I
always asked them to show me stuff I've
never seen before
don't go back to the same safe movements
only to really just keep exploring and
then the idea is artment to just keep
head contact so you can roll your heads
around but you do not take your heads
away you will contact the head sending
they're like moving even these
incredible forms and spirals and all
kinds of things and this woman just
comes up to me half
who says I don't know what's going on
but I've had knee injury for two years
and I haven't been able to get into
certain ranges and it's kind of it's
been really a problem on the map for me
but there's no pain anymore
and I can do this sounds like okay she
said can you tell me what's going on
so I joke about this I say yeah I'll put
my hands on her head and I said praise
the Lord
yeah but I just said like the starting a
new religions play the Lord and it's
basically been play enabled her to just
suddenly just put everything to one side
and start going to ranges because she's
focused on the partner in the activity
so it overrides the emotional trigger
within the injury which creates the
tension so the mind goes I'm gonna get
injured doing this creates tension which
creates inappropriate action there's
word again tension which then can lead
to further injury so it's a way of
overriding the injury for sunny start
moving in ways that you're not you
previously didn't perceive possible so I
guess within the spiritual realm it's a
much deeper version of that but with him
there would have been some kind of
trauma in that mid-back that would have
come from my guess very early years and
it was an opportunity to lift the lid
off that intellectual brain
yeah and allow the emotional trauma to
get out that's my perception of it yeah
I mean when I was listening you tell
that story I'm thinking about the
rigidity with which we you know kind of
live our lives and you know we're up in
our heads you know 95% of the time and
in order to get people you know out of
that modality and operating differently
to let go of kind of that protective
armor you have to turn the heat up very
slowly right first it's just walk around
and you need to get them used to that
before you know you're slowly you know
boiling that frog over time right and
then before they know it it becomes an
unconscious thing you're right but you
have to override the intellect and in
order to like connect with you know the
heart in a deeper way yeah and then you
get all the amazing happy hormones right
in this not almost I call it like the
happy the happy hormone shaker like the
cocktail shaker and you shake it around
and pop out comes a happy human
so the oxytocin serotonin it was amazing
little hormones that are kicking off in
that whole experience and that's the
Colette is a collective emotion they
start determining - so I guess going
back into that - going back into his
experience I think that's he's basically
again an intellectual did gets lifted
off and I think it mailed him to just go
in and unravel whatever trauma was
residing in there and since that moment
I think within period of time not six
months I think he is partner then got
pregnant I got married very quickly he's
been sued businesses just went through
the roof and took off his confidence was
completely different it was just
suddenly just a DIF just very different
being and so I just needed I just needed
to find out what it was thinking about
you got to get with the term and I think
it was that I think it was the rite of
passage that really did it for me it was
kind of like right okay I've been having
all these pseudo rites of passage
throughout my life I knew I need a right
passage and I felt that's probably
something this is a theme in your life
you know I think it was definitely
missing I kind of think it came down to
that the masculine in my life my father
and me not feeling like I'd had those
rites of passage also most people don't
you know that's been sort of eliminated
from the way that we grow up truly huh
yeah and I think that's medicine aside I
think these ceremonies are doing that I
think that's and even with wim you know
we've ice balls right it's a ceremony I
take people in the ice and it's and some
that have trauma and some that just
emotionally in pieces the day before on
the phone - not sure I can go through
this and nice bath but it's huge for
them and they have a massive
breakthrough within that process well I
think whether it's what you do or wim
HOF or ayahuasca or like Spartan races
like people are looking for whether you
want to call it a rite of passage or
just an authentic experience where
they're challenged in a visceral way out
in nature that's just something that
were we're hardwired to gravitate
towards that like I said we have
eliminated um the way in which we mature
as human beings and I think we need to
find ways of building that back in I
feel like now it's not until we reach
some level of maturity and how
some kind of you know crisis whether
it's emotional spiritual or existential
that we then avail ourselves of those
opportunities but what we need to do is
find ways to bring that back to the
youth so that they're experiencing that
as they mature and don't then set off on
that trajectory that leads to that
crisis later in life yeah and I think
that comes from our behavior again so
part of this journey for me is really a
lot of it was driven by Parenthood
becoming a father myself and mornings
become the best example our three
daughters so how do I become the best
example of a masculine if I haven't if I
haven't seen one gentleman you know I
haven't felt like I've been exposed to
one so part of that process especially
with the toad it felt like this is an
opportunity to become a better masculine
example to become a better man so what
the toad teach you it was at one point
when I when I spoke to a friend I said
it's all toad after that but anyway we I
fly to Ibiza to be with this guy Octavia
and with my friend who's been for this
ceremony and there's five of us it's
like a really intimate ceremony for the
five of us and the guy says he wants to
go first and I'll make you kidding me
I'm going first like this and and and
then the moment I inhale there is
nothing that's all I can say it's bit
like that white box up there I basically
just end to that but like Mike teevee in
a white box but I can't recognize T or
tawny or anything because there is no
Toni anymore I'm just part of the
whiteness and I've just immersed into
the whole thing any sense of
individuality or separate sense organs
and I'm just a frequency and then I hear
a frequency and the thing that's the
first thing I start to recognize as
something is it frequency
[Music]
that starts coming in and there's no oh
[ __ ] moment or what the hell's going on
or any of that no fear there is nothing
and then suddenly I start to feel like
I'm going through an evolution so I felt
like a water phase and I thought like
I'm in water but I'm almost drowning and
I'm trying to get this water out of me
and then I go through more of a
reptilian phase and I feel like I'm then
moving for that and no end I wound up
like this like I was in shackles I come
shackled but half bear half human in a
way not really interesting I tried to
find an image of it after that and I
came up with like a white human man
polar bear type things like really
interesting and then in in the in the
video that I get to see anyway so then
I'm roaring like this and in my head and
I'm broke three of these shackles and
there's a rule that comes out of me that
I felt almost like a really satisfying
burp like a I feels amazing that but it
was the raw and the roars like and then
every time I did it it just felt so
amazing like something I didn't know I
could even do or almost I wasn't allowed
to do it suddenly someone's now giving
me the freedom to rule
you know it's suppressed or something
which I guess aligns with the shackles
or whether there are incarnations or
side I don't know incarnated as a bear
or something I don't know lives maybe
and I've gone all the way through this
evolutionary model and experienced every
little detail of it as growth and then I
get to see the video and the video was
very tight as terrifying because that
you can see the moment I inhale and I'm
a strong guy but I suddenly I just
crumpled into this just almost like it
like I've died on the ground my hands
our code of my theater code up and I
guess I've gone back into I got feet on
a fetal position but the trauma of the
fetal position will cold in with my feet
in my hands and so that I think was the
trauma already just dissolving and
working through that which is
fascinating it goes into that deep layer
of the brain and so right in so I guess
the
reptilians store the brainstem net so
where the first initial traumas I think
are in the first thousand days right so
anything that happens in that most
instances stuff that we don't we can't
constantly remember any of that
but it stored somehow and will govern
how we perform throughout the rest of
our lives I guess so in that moment I
got to see it and in the video then you
can see me coming around then he's
pouring water trying to get me to
breathe and I realize I'm not I mean the
video girls are not breathing
I were and then he's almost like feels
looks like he's almost resuscitating me
in a way and then I start to make my way
up and then I'm right by this but I
can't see at that moment I wouldn't know
I'm looking at anything or seeing
anything
and then I stand and then you can see
then I'm going through this process of
these arms out and then looking up my
chest is exposed to the sky and I'm
screaming almost at that point and then
off I go and I go off into the woods and
I'm grabbing trees having this real nuts
relationship it's a short lived
experience though isn't there that was
probably in I'd say 12 minutes that
experience but I've gone through
evolution at that stage and I've turned
into different beings and had shackles
and broken free of them and then died
clearly and had had a full rebirth so
that was my first experience with it
okay how many of these have you done -
now - and then and and so and when I
arrived back from that Katerina's said
there's two there was two Tony's in her
life a Tony I am now an attorney she met
and she said Judas is just like it's
like it was like it's like being so what
did you get what is it Devi
again I just don't have the attachments
to things so there's no there's no
alcohol there's there's no I switched to
a plant-based diet I there's no drugs
there's no connection to any of that on
my approach is much softer as I think I
was I was frustrated and world
previously and I had someone come in to
see me who had a stomach cancer and they
had they were given a matter of days to
live and they remove like
80% of his stomach or something and he
survived it and he said that I said well
how traumatic that would you I mean what
was the experience for you so it was
really interesting us if you're going
tonight proper suffering and you know
how and because you can go both ways
with that he's denied I suddenly had a
real breakthrough again and it made me
look at simple things like the leaf or
the stone with a different eye I saw
beauty in every little detail every
little thing there was I could not have
experienced it as I'm part of it rather
than separate of it so I'm I am now the
rock and the leaf and but then I also
just saw saw his body and he and he said
the thing is though um I don't know
what's the matter with everyone he was
so miserable he said you know I just see
all this beauty and everything in my
wife she's so bloody miserable like this
and well man okay I get it I said I was
there I was there I had that I'm that I
reached the frustration stage and I said
and then eventually you just you can you
just have to be the change and be the
appropriate behavior for other people to
observe but also have compassion for
their trauma and their first six years
and the suffering that they have
inherited that could have been inherited
from their parents from their
grandparents from post-traumatic stress
disorder whatever we've inherited along
the path and you have to have compassion
and when you see it that way then again
you'll see the beauty in their behavior
and that's I think that's what came
through that first experience was to
just I could I became everything so I
would walk along the street and I'd be
amazed that I could hear so much I could
hear leaves and the birds and and
everything actually every little detail
I was absorbing which I think I'd maybe
locked out and dumbed out previously
right and also at the same time letting
go of the trauma and letting go trauma
and detaching yourself from and in
between that ceremony and the next I
mean I did a family constellation who
don't need family constellation know
what's the family constellation is um
this is incredible because it goes there
spiritual box there's the physiological
box then there's a social box and this
is where I put family constellation so I
attend this place with this woman mazing
practitioner and I go into a room and
there's I think 16 people all sitting
around in a circle and there's a chair
available for me so I go up and I sit in
the chair welcome everyone we have five
issue holders today can you put your
hands up and on either you hold up and I
still don't know what what I'm into said
well what is the issue holder I'm gonna
explains I don't even know at this stage
and and then they have the rest of their
as representatives so basically the
issue holders will be whatever your
issue is and I have psoriasis for me it
was like I have this issue is psoriasis
and I can't understand it because I have
I'm so aligned with my physiology now I
didn't a physical thing I haven't
aligned with to create what I perceive
as a bottle too enormous it has to be
residing somewhere else it's done this
spiritual work over here so why why do I
have it there's got to be this line of
ancestry it's coming in somewhere so
that's my issue and then what she would
do she then arranges the room with all
these people sitting around me in a
circle so before I got unlike number
five within the issue holders so there's
four people to go before me the first
one goes in and she says she sit in this
chest
available next to the lady and she's
right okay she calls her up and she sits
next to him she says okay so tell me
your heart's desire
he says I'm really you know I just oh
just stops crying immediately says I
just want to get pregnant and my family
hate my partner in and um it's just
life's terrible and anyway so she's okay
okay I think I know okay go and pick
someone to represent you so their
representatives you pick people to
represent who it is in your family which
is the constellation so she picked
someone to represent her and she
positions them wherever she feels in the
circle and then I went to go and pick
someone to represent your parents so she
goes off she picks this woman she puts
her there and she picks me so I'm now
the dad so I'm now standing next to her
mum we're side by side and the daughter
is opposite me uh-huh and then she
picked someone to represent her partner
so her partners next to her who's now
what was it the mum and the daughter is
opposite maybe being the dad and then I
went to pick someone who is the symptom
so the not being out not being pregnant
wanting to get pregnant that's the
symptom and they get put in the circle
as well so there's a four of us plus the
symptom and then the ladies still
sitting next to the facilitator and she
says right okay
how is everyone asking us how we are
verse one bit tripped out by what's
going on first experience with this and
everyone else is really conditioned they
just want to go to be representatives
and suddenly I feel like really awkward
and I'm sweating it was like really oh
why am i sweating and then I'm looking
at the woman next to me I just can't
bear to be next to her and I was just
and as I start moving away from who is
the wife in this situation who's the
mother and I get further and further
away and the further away I started
level off a bit and then I there's a
woman that's sitting over here that I'm
really drawn to so the lady stops the
whole thing she's hold on did your
father Hammond have an affair to the
woman she says no he didn't but he was
madly in love with this woman and she
died Wow okay so it's clearly her let's
bring her in so let's bring her in so as
you know so she asked the lady to stand
up and as she stands up I collapse on
the floor
I can't stop crying my chest is just
completely broken I'm I haven't ever
felt grief and heartbreak
like I felt in that moment and I just
can't speak and so she comes over and
says okay okay so then she's she's she
puts her hand on me and she asked me to
say to the lady I love you very much and
I'm really sorry our time together was
cut short but I'm with my family now and
hopefully we get to meet one day but I'm
now with this woman who I love and then
it enabled me to stand up and that was
all gone and then the lady sits down
again and then I'm put back in the
cerumen here and I can now stand next to
the woman who I just can bear to be next
to this couple over here and then the
issue the symptom feels better and the
symptom can come into the circle and
base it's just the way of stripping
things that have happened emotionally
within your
family constellation within your social
tribe so what do you make of that when
you had that visceral emotional
experience channeling you know this
other human being through your body well
firstly I wanted to know how she was
gonna clear it is mojang over who can I
have it
you've legitimately collapsed in grief
yeah so she basically just goes through
clearing with you but then you see
suddenly within the room that that's
then we in for the pros the next four
people that's the seis the same thing
until it's my turn to rock up you know
and so in the lunch break I remember
these people I felt like they had so
much drama going on around them so in
the lunch break I'm off and on and I
came back in and I said to the facility
I said you know I just don't think I've
got the Toolman like these guys I think
maybe you should let someone else go it
would make more sense someone who really
needs it I just don't fit she went we'll
see hmm and then I'd sit in exhale the
moment I said no so she said the person
who says that is the person who's
repressing the most yeah yeah did she
put so how do I know and she just said
um tell me about your dad I just said
you know this relationship and I love
him I love him very much but we just
didn't have this real connection and
okay that's enough go and pick someone
to represent you something to represent
your mother your father and the symptom
to arrange this thing where I'm next to
my mum like this and my dad's here and
the symptoms here uh-huh
and their opposite and so then she
dances right okay how does the symptom
feel and the symptoms like well I feel I
feel like he's not really on a Lonely
Island over here so she starts to then
say okay let's bring the parents in the
grandparents of my dad so they bring the
grandparents in and my grandmother then
is standing it's my dad like this and
he's dads over here so they're not
connected but then my my mom I then
hidden behind me so my mum doesn't have
a direct line to my grandmother and
there was some grief there between my
grandmother and my mother somehow anyway
my grandmother has psoriasis my dad has
psoriasis and then I okay let's bring
two more people in two more people in it
goes all the way back until the bench is
one person at the back here and I
suspect it's something to do being a
naughty Cal but anyway whoever it was
there was there was something going on
between the paternal line they've got
someone pregnant
and it could be in anything at that
particular time but it looked like there
the one with psoriasis and psoriasis was
the proof paternal proof within the
family that it went through this
constellation and that's what came out
with that ceremony but you're still
dealing with it yeah but not to what it
was you know went into I think we've
been a week of that it went into full
remission I didn't have any make sure
you're talking to that so there was no
there was nothing mm-hmm and I did that
woman get pregnant I don't know oh you
gotta find out no because I just it's
one of those things that you basically
step away from now have any connection
afterwards so then between that I then
go to I then rock up at the next Cyrus
and Aaron desert toed ceremony which ah
so from that from that ceremony from the
family constellation it's like the
relationships in my family got a bit
shifted after that so my relationship my
mom wasn't so intense it's much more
relaxed and the ratio of my dad softened
my sister my mum suddenly really
connected more than ever so they're now
living a very different life where
they're very involved together which
they weren't before it was kind of like
my mum smothered me you know then where
is that kind of broke that loose and my
sister now has a window so says stuff
changes within that which is quite
interesting you can you can heal that
social tribe again through ceremonies
like that so it's a form of
psychotherapy play to do yeah and it has
ties to Zulus where they'd love asking
ancestors for permission for things and
so yes going back so then the next
ceremony with the toad it was at a
friend's estate mm-hmm and there was a
large number of people there so it's
like we'd arranged a ceremony of like 20
people and all different things
happening and so they then said that you
know he wants to golf for us are you
kidding me I go and so this time
everyone in that ceremony pretty much
hit the deck so they go through the same
process of being on the floor and then
evolving but I didn't and I stood
through the whole ceremony
and I this dragon thing came up again
where I turned into a dragon in the
ceremony and on the video I'm standing
there doing a full-on hacker like a
proper tongue out my eyes had crossed
I'm doing stuff in my body that I've
tried to this day to replicate I can't
even get near it
just this rhythm of my spine it was
almost like my spine rippling my
shoulder blades about macaca like that
like the New Zealand exists right all
dance I'm doing something like that but
it's roaring all the way through and and
to the point where again it's that
primal raw coming through that is about
I now see it as I it was about finding
my voice and creating a space for me to
be able to speak and be able to rule and
doing work since then I worked with a
crystal healer who I was really sick I
was flying back to Ibiza it's like a
weekend and it was my birthday and it's
Tallulah's birthday and my anniversary
all wrapped into one thing and I'm on a
flight and it was a crowded flight
because it was it was season so there's
chaos all around people getting drunk
they're smashed and popping pills and
God knows where else was going on on the
flight and I'm just sitting there just
want to get back to my family and this
woman kept leaning over me of breathing
night god knows what in my face and I
just threw this I just put blindfold on
this I go to sleep but in say anything
you see I didn't speak I didn't say a
word
and I stepped off that fly in my throat
I got a con can hardly swallow and I
coul Katarina said oh we got plenty of
ginger in the place I feel something
going on my throat by the time I got
back to the house full-on temperature
throat was closing up felt like
tonsillitis and I'm react but I wake up
the next day feeling worse every
footstep I'm Aves like a shudder of that
horrible fever type feeling coming
through me all my joints aching and I
was determined because it was my
birthday anniversary and to Lunas
birthday just add ice for that we're
going to go to this play called wild
beats it's this amazing plant-based
restaurant
and we have some we'll have some rule
cake we're going to do that and I rock
up my friend Jamie's sitting outside
he's like this or smile I'm feeling so
rough and he says Tony you okay of
course I feel I'm gonna die but I'm here
because we need to do this it's okay
what's up I don't even ask man don't
worry about it said you been see a bee
he said you know happy I said oh happy
Dixon he said yeah yeah why will again
see a B so what he's doing crystal
healing she's incredible okay and I know
Abby I know how is teaching yoga and
doing this stuff I never connect to her
being here like let's say so for me I
thought yeah I'm just gonna go and do
this no I think you should go and see
her I was like you know man I don't have
the energy right now to go and see her
he said just think of what you'd say to
me if it was me he said of tell you what
yeah I'm gonna pay for it you're going
so he booked this appointment with a be
the healer I arrived at her place in the
afternoon and I stepped down the steps
and there's a swim important you set up
this mandala of crystals and she's right
k so tell me about your throat what's
going on with your throat and I said
I've gotta know what's going on as it
just happened on the fly explain the
thing and then she said right whatever
things go me your throat can you think
and I said John I remember my parents
taking me to see a speech therapist when
I was really young because I wouldn't
talk you know what was that about and I
said I don't know who taught apparently
they just said oh my parents walked in
oh and he's not talking and that's all I
seem to remember from the situation but
I don't remember a conversation
happening and around it so I wouldn't
have known what was going on just he's
not talking and pointing and I remember
through school I had trouble even
getting up and speaking to anyone or
reading aloud or any of these things and
so I lay down on this ceremony and she
puts always Chris's on me she puts one
on my throat and she and she and I could
for this he coming in here and then this
voice of whites your turn to speak now
all the animals have their voice and
then as I hear all the animals have your
voice have a voice I can hear peacocks
and birds and dogs barking all around me
all these noises coming out all the
animals and then she just lifts this
crystal off and it was like this just
this just this energy coming off my
throat I can't explain it I can't even
put into canto so it was don't really do
it justice but
just this feeling of something being
pulled off of me not pulling out of me
and it was almost in that moment I
realized that the trauma is going right
back into those boots that I was wearing
I was probably screaming crying and this
and it was all still happening to me and
nobody was stopping it so I think I
maybe stopped crying in that moment and
stopped screaming
and that's to do with me finding my
voice was dealing with that yeah the
whole thing has been this journey to you
reclaiming that voice isn't that amazing
it's all and having conscious awareness
of that and being able to do the work
and then being able to sit back and
analyze in going oh my god okay I see it
now I see the work and that's kind of
what came in with that with the with the
with becoming the dragon and becoming
the roaring and then meeting this
crystal healer and then since then so
named me to then step forward and do
things like this which would never have
even been on my radar before yeah you
know it just wasn't ever gonna happen
meaning doing what specifically being
able to talk Kody able to tone oh yeah
you don't have any problem at all no
something just where you do have you
remember being a quiet kid I remember I
remember being quiet and what people
would call shy but at the same time I
was really cheeky and I and I really
used to behave badly which I guess was
another way of speaking right well in
the you know kind of in retrospect
looking back at all these experiences
that you've had and the healing that's
taken place and the self-awareness and
everything that you've experienced like
how do you then take all of that and
like condense it and channel it into you
know becoming the kind of person that
you've become and the things that you do
now what I think that's the easiest part
because it's just about becoming and
being you know and once you strip all
that stuff away then then realize that
you can live authentically you can
actually be it so I had all the are all
the knowledge I know
there wasn't a thing I didn't know about
this physical social spiritual
experience it's about removing things
it's not it's it's it's deleting from
your experience being them being the
being that sounds like a cliche being
the change I want to see in the world
being the best example as a human being
and experiencing everything so almost I
went through this path of being a guinea
pig like trying all these things to get
this point where I could then speak the
truth and be the truth hmm you know it's
cool man
it's all your doing now I mean it's been
fun like watching your journey I mean
you came on my radar I think initially
through the happy pair guys yeah yeah
and they're like you got to check this
guy out and I started following your
stuff and I've seen you you know you've
done stuff with Tim shieff and you're up
in like you live in Camden but you're up
in like Hampstead all know I live in
Hampstead are you live in Hampstead I
have a studio space not a coach out of
in Camden okay that's gonna be moving
we're bait I'm involved with a property
developer haha and we're doing a
conscious co-working kind of space that
he said what would you do with a space
if it was yours
so I presented this whole model around
physical social spiritual needs and
creating a building where you go into
and you feel like those needs are being
met
so you're it's a play it's unlike a
typical co-working space where you just
go in and work like it's it's already
owned around right interests so that you
want to go back to it rather than basic
going back to this thing that 83% of the
UK live in urban environments and they
spend 90 percent their time indoors
uh-huh so what they spend ten percent in
their day outside if they're lucky is
that's 2.2 four hours what do you do in
those hours eight hours might be in the
bedroom right so you've got to clean up
the bedroom right you've got to get the
air purification plants in there change
the materials you're not breathing in
and out crap and change the light and
get amber lighting in so at least you're
getting their natural experience of
light which means all metabolism
hormones and everything can be regulated
but then the day time what are we doing
in the rest that time and how do we
again get those needs met sirs for
actually making that kind of connect
to a building so we're doing that
there's we got the 40 Boyd I think
September October put it on we get back
off my run ray that we time to open that
so yeah we live in a hamster I live
probably about 12 minutes away from the
ponds which is pretty caught up there
yeah I was up it I've never been to the
actual park but I was up when I was in
London I went to go see Brian Rose it
lives pretty close to there yeah as well
it's like it's super nice up there it's
beautiful yeah it's um
yeah we're blessed man yeah yeah I don't
think I could live in London if it
wasn't for that area yeah because the
village has you jump in that pond all
year long yeah man we were there um
things down 2-1
and we were cracking the ice there's
like a little dock to it you can jump
off on that Mayo pond the female pond
uh-huh so male pond is open all year
round then you have a mixed pond and we
do like a Sunday swim rise we have a
group of people that rock up men and
women aha
so we meet on a Sunday morning Sunday
morning were there doing our size
doesn't freeze over yes over the over
Christmas period we there was there was
a a week of like minus temperature so
there was one of the days when we walked
up and we're like on a break with the
ice to get in the mom the women over
there and she's like why are you so
excited I said this what it's all about
your caring lady so I didn't know how
many people show up she said okay all
right
how many people it depends man like the
the men's ponds just the other day was
rammed I mean to the point yeah the
whole changing area was full people were
spilling out onto the heath behind and
then it can be dead this sometimes just
two of us you know in the really early
mornings when it's freezing like that
and then it's just the men who don't
really swim you just climb down the
ladder and you hold on to the landing
you just do you just get to get find
that calm space uh-huh
and almost like I was writing about the
other day that we did a swim in the in
the ocean it was freezing he was in
Brighton there's a group of us not
influencers made up and we did some
breath lit a fire and got in and then
with us and and food afterwards and I I
found that roaring again and it felt so
gray in the sea because I suddenly
realized oh there's a different body of
water you almost had to take on the
water and rather than feeling many
insignificant in amongst the waves I've
become like who uh within it was amazing
I really just dumped loads of stuff in
there it's great and then with the ponds
it's different because this the water so
still there
so in that space you do become the water
in a different way it's much more calm
and peaceful and it sometimes just
doesn't feel right to swim there just
feels right you just sit there
mm-hmm and find that happy space until
suddenly you move and you got heart I
mean the water that's the amazing space
to get to so this summer you're gonna
run from the southern tip of England to
the to the north yeah we learn and
that's Lands End to John O'Groats right
30 miles a day for 30 days straight
that's right barefoot barefoot yeah
where did this idea come from I think
way back there probably good childbirth
and then brought to the surface by the
toad and everything along the way yeah I
again I did in our open have a piece of
bone I called it losing the shoes so I
think it's about losing those shoes I've
been thinking about it for a few years
and I don't know how you feel about with
vulture and I just felt that I almost
didn't feel mature enough to go and do
something like this I make sense mmm
didn't think I was gonna go and do it my
thirties I felt like I'd start doing
stuff like this in my forties and you
had to burn in the fire a little bit and
I'm always and I can run I mean I just
see run I don't see running as exercise
again I see it as a form of play and I
love doing it and we're at this point
now with sustainability and the
environment though I needed I felt to do
more and to be more for my kids again
comes down to children and raise
awareness for an environment that's
we're at this crisis point right now
so I thought what better platform to be
able to do that I could basically run I
think I addressed the original like I'm
going to do a marathon a day for however
many days and then everyday I can sit
down with a sustainability expert and
record them and I just had this idea I
know that's what I'm gonna do and then
it was as far as what I'm doing it it's
not I know I'm gonna do it I'm now doing
it and I'm gonna meet with whoever and a
contact whoever and then whoever I've
contacted so far you say are you kidding
me of course we're in and it's and it's
just growing that way yeah organically
really just in that seed that original
fault of have you lined up some call
sustainability experts to talk to actual
contact you Zak after Zak so we're gonna
do of course I'm not expecting to fly
over for a sustainability talk so we're
gonna do a virtual one with him nice I'm
also want to now get Greta on board you
knows Greta folk I think I'd be amazing
to be able to get her path I think for
my kids as well because they're really
inspired by her we listen to her
EU Parliament talk and the girls like is
amazing so we went straight to
extinction rebellion after that took the
girls they could experience that and
experience the energy of it and then
extinction rebellion so they're coming
on board
surfers against sewage which is Hugo and
I've got some sustainable fashion makes
Bert's I want to come and cover that so
I'm gonna go really everywhere with it
are you gonna document it very yell the
whole thing yeah and then I had a lady
approached me through Instagram DM me
just said I've got this film producer
friend of mine film director and he
wants to make a documentary out of it he
loves the idea and the concept of it so
that's what's happening and then I've
got few sponsors and then vivo or on
board as well so people are therefore on
board which is a strange sponsor as I'm
not wearing shoes but as we've sat down
and discussed it's not really about the
shoes it's about it's all about for me
it's lifestyle outside that so it's
almost like don't run in their shoes
live in their shoes because the idea of
living in their shoes means that your
feet aren't gonna be compromised when it
does come to you running whereas most
people have this feeling that I can just
wear whatever Footwear and
they're barefoot shoes on and I can
expect to run back home together so it's
the opposite it's almost like you're
better off just ditching that right and
wearing shoes that are gonna create your
foot shape it's roughly gonna come out
and appear in a contact Roth a happy
pair of course I'm gonna virus ya and
I'm hoping you're gonna come over yeah
yeah so what are the dates when you kick
in the singles the first of September
okay until the 30th gotcha
yeah and then might be able to make that
work please do yeah I got to pop in on
Mike Posner's walk across America first
yeah yeah so I told him I would do that
at some point this summer I don't know
but like that's pretty tempting that
sounds cool I haven't heard of Mike
Posner until your interview nice so
great and we've been playing his albums
ever since he's really great yeah one a
musician huh he's a beautiful guy yeah
and he just started this walk like I
think he's in New Jersey or just left
New Jersey I don't know he's you know
five days into it or something like man
I think it's pretty cool so where does
that we got to wrap this up soon but
where's where is the where does the
whole plant-based diet thing fit into
all of this for you well I basically I
went down a path of when I went in to my
retreats so start with him the space I
had and then the gym facility I had it
was all around finding what works in
nature in theory like what is the
natural beings of the planet what is it
they're doing and so we went down this
theory of primates hominin
hunter-gatherer farmer zoo human human
laboratory experience and then going
through that as a nutritional guideline
as well what were they doing so primate
is say 95% plant base 5% chimpanzees and
bonobos the ones that are closest
cousins let's say they still eat insects
and they occasionally hunt the monkey
right it's like a spiritual thing social
thing that they gather and they do and
it creates social order and their roles
are established it's quite an
interesting one there's a book called
hunting Apes and then as a hominin
weaver became scavenging primates so
there was nothing around and we'd go to
the carcass whatever was left and we'd
take the ligand
the tendons the marrow and whatever was
available and then as hunter-gatherers
then it's seen as we were hunting but
from the more research I do around it
depends on geographic location where you
are around the globe that there were
sacred animals and this is where we're
in a bit of a mess so they used to have
an experience with the animal and they
believe that animals almost sometimes as
higher beings and there were burial
sites for animals not human beings with
certain stages say it's to ask
permission from the animals and say that
we're going to him we even invite you
and give you a ceremony and so some of
those native tribes there's there's lots
of woven in stories around that process
but what we did we then came in and we
wiped out their main master species
let's say right so that's when farming
came in it disturbed a lot of that so
with farming whereas now we see in the
zoo human and the human laboratory
people are so disconnected from what
would have been sacred animals at some
stage and wild meat and wild animals and
and living a wild existence that people
talk about being paleo today there have
no connection to what paleo really truly
meant so they're eating domesticated
industrialized meats that are fed on
antibiotics and the second depressed
animals that are abused and whatever's
else in that chain so at some stage we
went down this Paleo path and it was
basically because of this model so it
was still having a connection to the
animal what we were doing and so my
retreats became about that where we'd
have wild me and we'd honor anyway a
process and we'd eat a predominantly
plant-based diet and then as time went
on I did a retreat and there was a robe
a chef called Diego Castro that came in
Diego's amazing and a beautiful being
and he just said look you know have you
thought about this and try there so we
they went down this path for trying to
be raw and of course going from what was
a clean plant-based prime a kind of diet
I would say to a hominin diet to undergo
a diet and then going straight into a
raw based diet
it made sense just my digestion wasn't
ready for it so had to be I had to
change things and then work on digestion
so I started then go really deeper into
what digestion is and then take it back
to what I perceived as like a primate
diet so I've kind of gone through this
path of primate to hominin mm-hmm to
hunter-gatherer to firstly seeing what a
domesticated tons gatherer was because I
was on a primary diet and then realizing
that on of me how are you eating this
crap man and then I discovered he was a
heavy wall the wall was protocol mm-hmm
which I thought was fascinating I
thought was fascinating from a
perspective she'd healed herself with MS
and then you realized that it's
basically just again she's predominantly
plant-based within that plan but there
were meats in there like she's doing
grass-fed grass water and she's got wild
meats in there so we went to do you guys
work with inside to bring on retreat so
we then did plant base for trees then we
lived in a visa and then we turned full
plant-based in Ibiza and then we came
back into London and then occasionally
we would then supplement with a little
bit while me and live a predominantly
plant-based yeah so real plant right
right yeah but I guess where I'm going
with that is I came to this conclusion I
didn't want to I didn't want anything to
be about an ism or bigot become attached
to I'm a paleo I'm a plant based on the
vegan on this and so I see things
differently within the nutrition world
now I see things like hey I want you to
get to a point where I understood why I
needed to eat innately almost and it was
why what I fear is what those
hunter-gatherers I'm talking about had
these ceremonies and sacred rituals they
were predominately plant-based again but
they would understand what it is they
need it so in foraging it's the same
experience they're moving through a
landscape becoming in the landscape and
being these amazing beings and
connecting to exactly what they need a
bit like any other animal that will eat
and other animals poop because it needs
some kind of bacteria within it so they
innately know what they need
given the chance given the opportunity
to be wild so it became about fasting
for me was a quickest way to kind of
achieve that so I'm for a bit of fasting
and then I did my sensory genomic
test my dip jump my genomics test sorry
23andme I did and now had someone read
that and there were some obvious stuff
in there and then I did some blood work
and then I did my microbiome and then I
did my Dosher so I kind of got an
understanding what the energy type needs
what the bacteria needs what the cells
need and what have I done there for me
I've trying to get this understanding of
what Tony needs and so if each and every
person understood exactly what they
needed I think it'd be very different
and we wouldn't have labels for anyone
and we wouldn't have thousands of books
on shelves trying to basically convince
people what they shouldn't shouldn't be
eating and I think short share arrogance
to tell someone what it is they need to
eat because nobody knows what an
individual person needs to eat because
we're so almost removed from it so I
think is for me it was about getting the
cleaner I could get my diet the more I
understood exactly what it felt like I
needed to eat and the more Intune I
could become with that innate ability so
I think for everyone to move towards a
plant-based diet to clean their diet up
and fasting if it works you're not gonna
tell anyone right now I'll go fast
because it's a protocol and I think you
have to have someone with you and
guiding you almost and understanding it
or go and see someone that can coach you
through that process but I personally
feel that those are probably the best
things you can do for yourself is to
have an understanding of what what it is
directly you need as an individual and
that works around the way that you move
the way that you sleep and the way you
eat and and your own individual
digestive system being moms being ya
know but what I what I would what I
would why am I not able to talk what I
want to say is that level of intuition
is contingent upon you being a fully
integrated person like somebody who has
done the work who is you know connected
to yourself in a very holistic way as a
result of all the things that you
described that you've gone through like
I feel like you're somebody who is in a
position to trust that impulse as it
arrives
like this is what I need this is what I
don't need I think most people are not
in that situation they're uh turley
disconnected from - they are there
they're not even consciously aware of
the patterns that they're running and I
don't need to tell you this you know
this and so for that person to say well
I need this like that's a very
untrustworthy impulse yeah again going
back into those first six years you know
the emotional attachments to food really
start back there so if you dare say
forums in which you um you fell over and
your mama and your puppet say oh here
you go here's a chocolate bar and what
you really needed was someone to either
brush off your knee pat you on the back
and say it's gonna be fine or give you a
hug and show some love so already the
Mars bar represents something else much
deeper so it's no longer even a food
group it now has an emotional attachment
to something else and we have that food
foods parents use foods for bribery
you know grandparents especially they're
very good at that they go aren't you
very good let's have some of this or
let's do this and they use praise and
use punishment and they use guilt and
these briber it is very interesting
tools of its manipulative but the
problem with that is again it misaligns
us again it moves up off the path of
again what would be an innate ability
and emotional ability to deal with food
so how do we strip that back and that's
where I think things like fasting really
I think they do really benefit I think
it's an ad enables us just a step back I
think also just going through simple
things that right get off get off the
food groups that are hugely addictive
all right these sugars and just move
just try and step back a bit recognize
that's what they are to begin with and
then fast and then try and find a way of
fasting even if it's through a
particular food group or something you
identify my thing was salt and vinegar
crisps yeah why my dad used to go out on
a Friday night we just didn't used to
seeing the whole time he'd gun play
snooker with his pals down the pub after
not seeing him a week we still could
manage to go down the pub play snooker
we had no money but you still had enough
money to go and drink smoke and play
snooker and buy salt and vinegar crisps
and leave them under my pillow so I
wake up in the morning I'd have salt and
vinegar crisps and it wasn't that one
moment though she hasn't been a good
Chris
men love fried you understand so the
hardest thing on my whole path was
actually some vinegar Chris well they're
also just sour mix it is the perfect
combination of salt and fat and texture
yeah but it's fascinating all wrapped up
in one yes yeah because it means so much
all right well we got a we got to end
this but let's let's leave people with
just a couple things that they can build
into their lives that could perhaps
shift their perspective on you know how
we're living how we're moving to make
things a little bit healthier yeah goes
back into what I said earlier like we
can't live in nature but it doesn't mean
we can't live naturally so the bedroom
we spend a large portion of our time in
that one room I have one person I spoke
to and they've had their house for 30
years I've been sleeping in the same
room for 30 years that's the same linear
experience
Zach's work same microbiome experience
in that same environment so I would look
at that one space to begin with how do
you clean it up how do you bring more
nature into that space so you can have
plants you for air purifiers in there
clean up the air I think is one of them
biggest things you can do for yourself
because there's stuff that's being
kicked out from the paint's the mastics
the glues the carpets the mattress all
the soft furnishings that are all
neurotoxins Ryan if you understand
sensory genomics you understand that
depression Alzheimer's dementia all
these things that the basic can be
coming through neurotoxins so that's
that's one thing I would look at clean
cleaning that up then obviously the
materials that you use in your bedroom
so if if you if you have the money go
and buy stuff that's more of a natural
fiber if you can do it lighting there's
some really great stuff out there you
can buy even just for bedside lamps
after your main main bedroom light but
you could do bedside lamps and there's
one company called aura glow and it's
just a simple remote control pop them in
you can put them on strobe for the kids
so they can party you can have blue
light and below
what a purple like whatever you want but
my advice is to put them on amber why is
that important so we could look at three
geographic locations of hunter-gatherers
and study them I think nervous 30 and
one study is 33 members of a tribe
studied over two hundred and twenty-two
days
how long do you think they're all asleep
together it's like 18 minutes all right
over that length of time 33 members so
not one of them is getting eight hours
sleep they sleep between 5.7 and 7.1
hours and they do through the poly faces
almost like they are in their real REM
sleep there's the most important staff
in the lightest part of their sleep
they're up and they're tending to the
fire looking after the young fixing
tools smoking and partying and then they
go back to sleep again and then they
reach the rim so they do that throughout
the night life a sec approach exactly
and that's in three separate geographic
locations they've studied that and so
what's different what's different is air
temperature like you're sleeping in
tents we know that's the air temperature
is different the lighting is different
the air quality is different right their
daily activities are different so they
get up before the Sun comes up so
they're already moving in that stage
when the Sun Goes Down it's not like no
the light's gone off I go to sleep that
doesn't happen it's around about 10:00
p.m. 9:00 and 10:00 they go to sleep so
trying to look at things like that
what's the natural environment for sleep
what happens in nature rather than
looking at scientific studies that are
formed in a laboratory because I only
gives you the laboratory experiment
that's not how it works you need to look
at nature to understand what a natural
circadian rhythm is not a circadian
movement in a laboratory so I'd go down
that path to try and bring nature in and
try and make that more of a natural
experience movement okay so if you're in
an office and you your HR department
won't allow you to have a standing desk
again you slide your chair away you do
some squats I have a whole sport
tutorial that we can we can send out to
the listeners as well yeah it's great
like I'll put a link in the show so we
can do this and then that gives you some
tips as well with what you can be doing
behind the desk 10,000 steps everyone
loves banging on about 10,000 steps but
for me if you have
10,000 poor steps that might lead you to
an injury is probably not the best model
if you're wearing compromised Footwear
with a dodgy heel and a pointed toe box
it's not the best model so I would go
most people are aware in those kind of
right yeah I would cut back and just say
right okay what's the more natural
environment for a foot its nature it's
creating a foot shaped shoe so go to
minimal Footwear there's some amazing
brands out there vivos one but there's
others there's some primal office where
that's come through and it's trying to
basically even that get into the feeling
that it's not about running in those
shoes it's about living in those shoes
and that will give you a great amazing
foundation so if you're into all your
disciplines it could be pilates yoga
could be running what we're talking
about and it will only enhance that
those disciplines will just get better
because you'll be moving in the
appropriate systems and creating the
right muscle action tendon actions for
them which means the next day you can
get up and do the same thing without the
tension so there's movement and sleep
clean up your diet again high
vibrational foods keep it really clean
the cleaner it gets the more innate
things will become for you there's
another yeah sleep rest I think that's a
good list I think that's a good list
yeah I mean if you could master just
that you're well I'm doing a book with
all this I'm basing should be yeah at
the moment is just I'm just trying to
find the right publisher in there and
but it yeah it's basically you have a
title but Dave I don't want to let it go
now I don't know what the publishing was
like Fung's you tell me after we start
anyway yeah pleasure my friend that was
amazing awesome thank you so much
beautiful thing if people want to learn
more about this impending multi-day run
or just what you're up to in general
where's the best place for them to go my
Instagram at the natural life stylist
and my website is Tony riddle gotten
calm and for the run are you gonna have
a skip like can people come out and run
with you yeah that's what we're working
re working on depending on what
sustainability experts coming in and
what part of the journey they're gonna
be on then we can map out the full group
sit stick the itinerary up and then
people can come and jump on board all
right man and definitely everybody check
out his Instagram
he's always up to like crazy cool stuff
and I always learned something there so
appreciate you appreciate your time
today I've already learned like so much
and come back again and share with me
some more definitely what you were going
to come over to yeah yeah yeah yeah we
can do something all right cool thanks
my piece
[Music]